programming throwdown episode number four matlab and octave take it away jason man episode number four it's pretty pretty epic it's a milestone for yeah yeah it's uh eight weeks yeah there we go eight weeks we have soon we'll be at 140 yeah that's right we have uh what is it like uh over 150 downloads so uh quite a few of you have been listening and so we appreciate that yeah got a number of reviews on iTunes, five stars. Thank you all for doing that. Yeah, that's good times, good times. So I think there was something in the news about like Amazon
Programming Throwdown 第四期，Matlab 和 Octave，Jason，开始吧。第四期，真是太史诗了，这是一个里程碑。是的，八周了，没错，八周了。我们很快就会达到 140 期，没错，我们有超过 150 次下载，所以有很多听众在收听，我们对此非常感激。iTunes 上也有不少评论，五星好评，感谢大家的参与。是的，那段时光很美好。我想新闻里提到了亚马逊
with their like EC2, their cloud server went down. Did you see that one? Yeah, it was all over the news all day. Saw a bunch of that. Their web services went down. I guess it was all of them, their S3, EC2, all of them. Oh, really? I thought it was just EC2.
他们的 EC2，云服务器宕机了。你看到了吗？是的，整天都在新闻里。看到了很多相关报道。他们的网络服务宕机了。我想是所有的服务，S3、EC2，全宕了。哦，真的吗？我以为只是 EC2。
Maybe. Okay, I'm not really sure about that. But, yeah, I saw that Amazon's stuff went down. And it's interesting how many popular websites now are actually running on top of Amazon's web service. I guess that's a praise of how good it really is. But things like Quora, which is a question and answer site was down. I know Heroku, which is a was bought. Who is it bought by?
也许吧。好吧，我不太确定。但确实，我看到亚马逊的东西宕机了。有趣的是，现在有多少热门网站实际上是运行在亚马逊的网络服务之上的。我想这算是对它性能的一种赞誉吧。但是像 Quora 这样的问答网站也宕机了。我知道 Heroku，它被收购了。是被谁收购的？
Oh, well, it's a company that's a platform as a service and they host like Ruby apps and stuff. And I know they were down. I think Dropbox was even having problems. Pretty much, you know, a large portion of the popular websites we go to and use every day use Amazon Web Services as a back-end because they've done such a good job making it so cheap and reliable. And then it goes down, and then it's like, uh-oh, the world comes to a halt. Yeah, I mean, this is similar to, what was that one company?
哦，那是一家提供平台即服务的公司，他们托管 Ruby 应用之类的。我知道他们也宕机了。我想 Dropbox 甚至也遇到了问题。基本上，我们每天访问和使用的大部分热门网站都使用亚马逊网络服务作为后端，因为他们做得很好，既便宜又可靠。然后它宕机了，就像，噢，糟糕，世界停摆了。是的，我的意思是，这和那家公司很像，是哪家来着？
It started with an E, that they did email surveys, and they got hacked. And as a result, your email and your name got leaked out. Oh, yeah, a couple weeks ago. Yeah. I got an email from TripAdvisor saying that my email got leaked out. And then I got one from the university that I was a student at. And it's almost the same exact email every time. I got another one from, I think, American Airlines.
名字以 E 开头，他们做电子邮件调查，然后被黑了。结果，你的电子邮件和名字被泄露了。哦，是的，几周前。是的，我收到 TripAdvisor 的邮件说我的邮箱被泄露了。然后我又收到我曾就读的大学发来的邮件。每次邮件内容几乎一模一样。我想我还收到了美国航空发来的另一封。
And all of them used this one service that had an exploit. Yeah. So it's common. It's surprising because a lot of people let their, what do they call it, I guess, white labeling, right, where you make a product, but then somebody else can basically put their own label on it or their own front end or high.
它们都使用了这个有漏洞的服务。是的，所以这很常见。这很令人惊讶，因为很多人让他们的，他们称之为什么，我想是白标（white labeling），对吧？你制造一个产品，然后别人基本上可以贴上他们自己的标签，或者他们自己的前端。
It's not obvious to people that you're using their backend. And so, yeah, it's kind of interesting that when Amazon went down, all these websites that are completely unrelated to Amazon went down as well. And the e-company was Epsilon. Oh, that's right. Epsilon. That's it. So, yeah, hopefully they'll come back.
人们并不清楚你在使用他们的后端。所以，当亚马逊宕机时，所有这些与亚马逊完全无关的网站也随之宕机，这很有趣。那家 E 开头的公司是 Epsilon。哦，对了，Epsilon。就是它。所以，希望他们能恢复。
I guess maybe they're back by now. But, yeah, it was down for a couple hours or whatever, which is a pretty big deal with their increase in popularity. I guess they've been down once before. And when that happened, it was a while ago. They weren't quite as popular. And they came out and were really apologetic and said, you know, we're not going to settle in making our product better until it's perfect.
我想他们现在可能已经恢复了。但是，确实，它宕机了几个小时，考虑到他们日益增长的受欢迎程度，这可是件大事。我想他们之前也宕机过一次。那次发生时，是很久以前了。他们当时还没那么受欢迎。他们出来道歉，并说，我们不会停止改进产品，直到它完美为止。
Right. I mean, the interesting thing about the Amazon cloud is just how accessible they've made it. I mean, there's that library, that Python library, PyCloud, where you can take Python code and run it on the Amazon cloud with, like, virtually no effort. It just literally takes your function calls and tries to guesstimate. I think you might have to provide it, like what actual data you think that function is going to use. But it handles sending it to the cloud, and you can pull the cloud and say,
没错。关于亚马逊云，有趣的是他们让它变得多么容易获取。我的意思是，有一个库，那个 Python 库 PyCloud，你可以用它编写 Python 代码，然后几乎不费吹灰之力就在亚马逊云上运行。它实际上只是获取你的函数调用并尝试进行估算。我想你可能需要提供一些信息，比如你认为该函数会使用什么实际数据。但它处理发送到云端的过程，你可以轮询云端并询问，
are you done yet, are you done yet? And then as soon as it's done, it'll let you know. And so you can be using the cloud right now um from python and many other languages uh with just a trivial amount of work and that's that's very interesting it really puts a lot of power in our hands yeah and it's obviously lucrative for amazon i i saw some some article we don't have this in our news but they were talking about that oh you're pointing out to me that dropbox runs on top of of storage and how much a year I was in the millions that Dropbox is paying for. Yeah, it was about $4 million a month.
你完成了吗？你完成了吗？一旦完成，它就会通知你。所以你现在就可以从 Python 和许多其他语言中使用云服务，只需极少的工作量，这非常有趣。它确实把很多权力交到了我们手中。是的，这对亚马逊来说显然是赚钱的。我看到了一些文章，虽然我们新闻里没有提到，但他们谈到了 Dropbox 是如何运行在存储之上的，一年要花多少钱，是数百万美元。是的，大约每月 400 万美元。
Oh, a month? Yeah. Oh, wow. I thought it was like per year. So, yeah, they're paying a lot of money to Amazon to do this because it's so accessible. It's so easy to use, and they're doing it at a fair enough cost. You know, it's cheap.
哦，一个月？是的。哦，哇。我以为是每年。所以，是的，他们付给亚马逊很多钱来做这件事，因为它太容易获取了。它太容易使用了，而且成本也相当合理。你知道，它很便宜。
Yep. So what have you been spending a large portion of your last day or two doing? So I've been pretty into Portal 2. It was a lot of fun to play. I won't give any spoilers. Now do we need to spoil? Okay, I was going to ask. No, no, I won't spoil anything, although I will say that the story is amazing.
没错。那么你过去一两天大部分时间都在做什么？我最近沉迷于《传送门 2》。玩起来很有趣。我不会剧透的。我们需要剧透吗？好吧，我本来想问的。不，不，我不会剧透任何东西，尽管我要说故事非常棒。
There are a lot of twists, which, you know, assuming that no one has spoiled it for you, you will find very enjoyable, especially if you've played the first one, because it requires sort of a lot of the knowledge from the first to fully appreciate the storyline. But yeah, so Portal 2 is kind of interesting. So they preloaded all of the data for the game onto your machine when you pre-purchased the game. So in my case, I pre-purchased it about a month ago, and it actually loaded all of the content at that time. And Half-Life 2 did this as well, but one thing that Portal did that's unique is they encrypted all of the data. So, you know, when I got up in the morning uh the day portal 2 was released i guess three or four days ago um i actually it took about an hour and it went through
有很多反转，如果你没被剧透的话，你会觉得非常享受，特别是如果你玩过第一部的话，因为它需要第一部的大量知识才能完全欣赏剧情。但是，是的，《传送门 2》很有趣。他们在你预购游戏时，就把所有数据预加载到了你的机器上。就我而言，我大约一个月前预购的，它当时就加载了所有内容。《半条命 2》也这样做过，但《传送门》做了一件独特的事情，就是他们加密了所有数据。所以，当我早上起床时，也就是《传送门 2》发布的那天，我想是三四天前，它实际上花了一个小时，完成了
and decrypted all of the data that it had downloaded and then also uh as part of decrypting you know downloaded the executable and started running. Interesting. So what encouraged you, this is digitally available, right? Whatever. So what encouraged you to pre-buy it, give them your money early? So in this case, they gave a deal. So for, yeah, so for, if you pre-purchased, you could, you get 10% off and you also got a free copy of Portal 1 that you could gift to somebody else. Considering you probably already had Portal 1, if you were that interested in Portal 2. Yeah, exactly. So, yeah, Portal 2 actually had another interesting thing
解密所有已下载的数据，然后作为解密的一部分，下载了可执行文件并开始运行。有趣。那么是什么促使你预购的，毕竟它是数字版，对吧？是什么促使你提前付钱给他们？在这种情况下，他们给了一个优惠。所以，如果你预购，你可以获得 10% 的折扣，还可以获得一份免费的《传送门 1》副本，你可以送给别人。考虑到如果你对《传送门 2》那么感兴趣，你可能已经有《传送门 1》了。是的，完全正确。所以，《传送门 2》其实还有另一件有趣的事情，
where originally there was rumors that they were going to release the game on Friday, a couple of Fridays ago. And then they decided, or on Friday they announced that if you bought the potato pack which is a set a collection of indie games for each for these little sort of achievements or little aspects of these different indie games that you accomplished you know in one of them it was every time you beat a level you would earn a potato and once a certain number of potatoes had been accumulated by the entire community,
最初有传言说他们会在周五发布游戏，大概是几周前的周五。然后他们决定，或者在周五宣布，如果你购买了“土豆包”（Potato Sack），这是一套独立游戏合集，通过完成这些不同独立游戏中的小成就或小环节，比如在其中一个游戏中，你每通关一个关卡就会获得一个土豆，一旦整个社区积累了足够数量的土豆，
everyone on Steam, the Portal 2 game would become unlocked. Interesting. Yeah, so this is kind of a double-edged sword. A lot of people felt like, you know, we waited so long for this game, and now you're making us buy these games that we don't even want to play so that we can get to Portal 2. But a lot of other people thought it was kind of fun and a little ingenious of them to you know make some extra money and also you know provide some
Steam 上的每个人，《传送门 2》游戏就会解锁。有趣。是的，这有点像双刃剑。很多人觉得，我们等这个游戏等了这么久，现在你却强迫我们买这些我们根本不想玩的游戏，才能玩到《传送门 2》。但也有很多人觉得这很有趣，而且他们很聪明，既赚了额外的钱，又提供了
entertainment and give uh you know give a little love to uh the people who make indie games so yeah interesting now one thing i was thinking about when i saw that we were going to be talking about portal 2 was the fact that i don't i guess it was a couple months ago i could have been longer now when they originally had their release date and people were getting all excited and then valve came out and said you know oh is it valve i don't know whoever yeah valve okay they came out and said that um yeah it's going to be delayed sorry making software is harder than we thought, or is hard. And so I thought that was kind of interesting that they said,
娱乐，还给制作独立游戏的人一点关爱。所以，很有趣。现在，当我看到我们要讨论《传送门 2》时，我想到的一件事是，我想大概是几个月前，或者更久，当他们最初定下发布日期时，人们都很兴奋，然后 Valve 出来说，哦，是 Valve 吗？我不知道，随便吧，是的，Valve，好吧，他们出来说，嗯，要推迟了，抱歉，制作软件比我们想象的要难，或者说很难。所以我认为他们说的话很有趣，
yeah, this is hard. It's going to take longer. We're going to make it awesome. We're not going to release it any sooner. And that's interesting as a programmer, and I'm like, yay, that's true. Making software is hard. Oh, that sounded very enthusiastic. So, yeah, I mean, it's really hard to do software estimation, you know,
是的，这很难。需要更长时间。我们要把它做得非常棒。我们不会提前发布。作为程序员，这很有趣，我就想，耶，这是真的。制作软件很难。哦，听起来很热情。所以，我的意思是，进行软件估算真的很难，你知道，
saying how long is this function going to take to write? How long is this level going to take to make? How long is it going to take to test this feature? It's hard to estimate that, especially if you're doing something, you know, new or never been done before. Yeah, I mean, really, at this level, programming is almost an art. And, you know, in general, you just cannot put a time on, you know, art. It's just there's a level of creativity. And often it's there's just no such thing as perfect, you know.
说这个函数需要写多久？这个关卡需要多久才能做出来？测试这个功能需要多久？很难估算，特别是如果你在做一些新的、以前从未做过的事情时。是的，我的意思是，真的，在这个层面上，编程几乎是一门艺术。而且，总的来说，你无法给艺术设定时间。它只是存在一种创造力。而且通常情况下，根本没有所谓的完美，你知道。
You can, you know, if you have a function and it needs to add two numbers or whatever, then there is, you know, obviously a perfect answer to that. But often things come down to. Maybe not, but most of the time. Yeah, it depends what world you're living in. But, you know, often things come down to... Maybe not, but most of the time. Yeah, it depends what world you're living in. But, you know, often these come down to design choices. And design is something that's never perfect. It always comes down to your interpretation
你可以，如果你有一个函数需要相加两个数字之类的，那么显然有一个完美的答案。但通常事情归结为……也许不是，但大多数时候是。是的，这取决于你生活在什么世界。但是，你知道，通常事情归结为……也许不是，但大多数时候是。是的，这取决于你生活在什么世界。但是，你知道，通常这些归结为设计选择。而设计是永远不会完美的。它总是归结为你的解读，
and different designs fit different forms, you know, more optimally or sub-optimally. So, you know, optimally or sub optimally so you know yeah again designing software and uh you know implementing software at a high level is very unpredictable yeah that's true yeah it's true but yeah everybody always thinks we can do it we are able to predict and figure it out and make a number even though the numbers are tend to mostly be really wrong yeah yeah definitely. Unless it's very similar to something you've done before,
不同的设计以更优或次优的方式适应不同的形式。所以，你知道，是的，再次强调，在高层面上设计和实现软件是非常不可预测的。是的，这是真的，但每个人总是认为我们可以做到，我们能够预测并弄清楚，并得出一个数字，尽管这些数字往往大多是非常错误的。是的，绝对是。除非它和你以前做过的非常相似，
in which case it's important, as much as we all hate the infamous M word, metrics. They're terrible. They can be useful because as you build up enough of a backlog of history of what something was, how long it took you, what you thought it would take you, you can begin to learn a lot and do that kind of introspection and say, how long, how have I estimated in the past and begin to improve your estimates and get better at them and, uh, or compare with other people and say, you know, what are you using? What numbers are you taking?
在这种情况下，重要的是，尽管我们都讨厌那个臭名昭著的 M 开头的词，指标（metrics）。它们很糟糕。它们可能很有用，因为当你积累了足够的历史记录，了解某件事是什么、花了多长时间、你认为它会花多长时间时，你就可以开始学习很多东西，进行那种内省，并说，我过去是如何估算的，并开始改进你的估算，变得更好，或者与其他人比较并说，你用的是什么？你用的是什么数字？
But I guess a lot of companies treat it as proprietary, but you know, if your company uses that or does that, you know, if they fuss you about metrics, sometimes there's a good reason, not all the time, but sometimes it is helpful to make estimations better yeah i mean you'll notice that a lot of the people who are in charge of you know cost and estimation are senior and that's just because that's not something that you can really learn in school it's something that you have to kind of just do a lot of software and get down to, you know, make estimations that are wrong and find out, you know, along what dimensions did you spend a lot of time and then what are the areas in which there is a lot of variability.
但我猜很多公司把它视为专有信息，但你知道，如果你的公司使用或这样做，如果他们因为指标而对你大惊小怪，有时是有充分理由的，不是一直都有，但有时这有助于使估算更好。是的，我的意思是你会注意到，许多负责成本和估算的人都是资深的，那只是因为这不是你在学校里真正能学到的东西，这是你必须通过做大量的软件，然后弄清楚，做出错误的估算，并找出你在哪些维度上花费了大量时间，以及哪些领域存在很大的变异性。
And so a lot of the senior engineers will kind of have a good understanding, just an intuition on how long something will take. Although we do like to complain that they make the estimates, but then they don't have to do the work. That's always a dangerous situation if somebody else gets to make the estimates. Yeah, exactly. Not the people having to do the work. Yeah.
所以很多资深工程师会有一种很好的理解，仅仅是一种直觉，知道某件事需要多长时间。虽然我们确实喜欢抱怨他们做出了估算，但他们却不必去做这项工作。如果让别人来做估算，那总是一个危险的情况。是的，完全正确。而不是那些必须做这项工作的人。是的。
So on games, did you hear the rumors that were flying all around about the Wii 2? Yeah, yeah. It looks pretty cool. I like how, you know, the Wii is sort of coming out of the gate early with the Wii 2, considering that the Wii doesn't have a lot of the, you know, HD, you know, graphics capabilities as some of the other consoles. So you heard any of, what are the good rumors you've heard so far? Well, I've heard that it'll launch early 2012. All right.
那么关于游戏，你听到关于 Wii 2 的传言了吗？是的，看起来很酷。我喜欢 Wii 2 这么早就出场的方式，考虑到 Wii 本身并没有像其他一些主机那样拥有很多高清图形处理能力。所以你听到了什么好的传言吗？嗯，我听说它会在 2012 年初发布。好吧。
That's not that far from now. No, it's pretty soon. You know, the Wii, I believe you looked it up, right? The Wii was the last one of the three. Yeah, it was right around the same time, I think, as the PlayStation 3. Yeah. But pretty close, yeah. But I haven't heard anything about a new Xbox or a PlayStation 4. No, no.
离现在不远了。不，很快。你知道，Wii，我相信你查过，对吧？Wii 是三者中的最后一个。是的，我想它和 PlayStation 3 差不多在同一时间。是的。但很接近，是的。但我还没听说过新的 Xbox 或 PlayStation 4。不，不。
What is it going to be, Xbox 720 now? Yeah, let's try the Tony Hawk version. Oh, or the 1080 4. No, no. What is it going to be? Xbox 720 now? Yeah, that's right. The Tony Hawk version. Oh, or the 1080, the Sean White version. Yeah, that's right. Yeah, so I heard that they were talking about maybe having touchscreen controllers for the Wii because that was a big deal that, you know,
现在会是什么，Xbox 720 吗？是的，试试 Tony Hawk 版本。哦，或者 1080 4。不，不。现在会是什么，Xbox 720 吗？是的，没错。Tony Hawk 版本。哦，或者 1080，Sean White 版本。是的，没错。是的，所以我听说他们正在讨论 Wii 可能配备触摸屏控制器，因为那是一个大事件，你知道，
the Wii 1 kind of forsook going the route of blingy eye candy and instead went the route of having new intuitive controls and having the ability to get up and dance around your TV and look completely stupid. But people loved it. And when they did, it kind of helped them capture a whole new audience of people that weren't into gaming before, is the idea.
Wii 1 放弃了走炫目视觉效果的路线，而是选择了拥有新的直观控制，并且能够站起来在电视前跳舞，看起来完全像个傻瓜。但人们喜欢它。当他们这样做时，它帮助他们吸引了一大批以前不玩游戏的新受众，这就是想法。
And that's pretty interesting that they did that. So it would be cool if they kind of continued that weren't into gaming before is the idea. And that's pretty interesting that they did that. So it would be cool if they kind of continued that path and say, everybody else now kind of has motion controllers, right? And Xbox even has the Kinect, which has no controller to do the motion. That's kind of cool, and everybody's kind of catching up. So now it would be interesting to see if they're able to actually leapfrog everybody again and say, yeah, we are totally going to do this new amazing thing nobody else was even thinking about.
他们这样做非常有趣。所以如果他们能延续那种以前不玩游戏的受众的想法，那就太酷了。而且他们这样做非常有趣。所以如果他们能延续那条道路，说，现在每个人都有运动控制器了，对吧？Xbox 甚至有 Kinect，它没有控制器来做运动。这很酷，每个人都在赶上来。所以现在看看他们是否能再次超越所有人，说，是的，我们绝对要做这个没人想到的新的惊人事情，那会很有趣。
That would be pretty cool. Yeah, one thing that Nintendo did, which it didn't catch on just because of the price point and the way that gaming works in the U.S., but it was pretty popular in Japan, and it was actually awesome technology. The GameCube had a thing where you could plug in gameboy advances uh into the gamecube as many as there were players and um you would actually play on the gameboy
那会很酷。是的，任天堂做过一件事，它没有流行起来只是因为价格点和美国游戏运作的方式，但在日本非常受欢迎，而且确实是了不起的技术。GameCube 有一个功能，你可以把 Game Boy Advance 插入 GameCube，有多少玩家就插多少个，然后你实际上可以在 Game Boy
advance um and so there would be one screen so the gamecube would be on your tv just like you know regular console and that screen would be shared by everyone. But your Game Boy Advance controller has its own screen since that's a portable console itself. And that screen would be private information that only you could see. So, for example, there was a game called Four Swords, Legend of Zelda Four Swords. And it was a multiplayer Legend of Zelda. And you could actually hurt the other players so that you could take their rubies. So as part of the game, not only were you trying to get through the dungeon like a traditional Zelda dungeon crawler, but you're trying to get through with the most points and that might mean
Advance 上玩，所以会有一个屏幕，GameCube 会在你的电视上，就像普通主机一样，那个屏幕由所有人共享。但你的 Game Boy Advance 控制器有它自己的屏幕，因为那本身就是一个便携式主机。那个屏幕将是只有你能看到的私人信息。例如，有一个游戏叫《四支剑》，《塞尔达传说：四支剑》。它是一个多人《塞尔达传说》。你实际上可以伤害其他玩家，这样你就可以拿走他们的红宝石。所以作为游戏的一部分，你不仅要像传统的塞尔达地牢探索者那样通过地牢，而且你还要争取以最高分通过，这意味着
sabotaging the other players. And so they use the, you know, screens built into the controllers to, you know, give you private information and allow for these competitive games and these sort of treachery, treacherous games. I think I remember there being, I don't think I ever played it that way, but I remember seeing pictures of people in football games being able to select the plays on their Game Boy Advance. Yeah, that's right. And so the problem at the time was that, you know, you had to either buy four Game Boy Advances and a GameCube or have three friends with Game Boy Advances who all wanted to play that game.
破坏其他玩家。所以他们使用内置在控制器里的屏幕来给你私人信息，并允许这些竞争性游戏和这些背叛性的游戏。我想我记得有，我不认为我曾经那样玩过，但我记得看到人们在足球游戏中能够在他们的 Game Boy Advance 上选择战术的照片。是的，没错。所以当时的问题是，你必须要么买四个 Game Boy Advance 和一个 GameCube，要么有三个有 Game Boy Advance 的朋友，他们都想玩那个游戏。
And so that was the challenge. That's what kind of killed it. You mean nerds had to actually get together in the same place and socialize? Yeah, it was pretty much impossible. So that was the end of that. But I'm hoping with these touchscreen controllers that they will sort of bring back some of that. That's a good call. That's interesting.
所以这就是挑战。这就是导致它失败的原因。你是说书呆子们必须真正聚在同一个地方并进行社交？是的，这几乎是不可能的。所以这就是它的终结。但我希望通过这些触摸屏控制器，他们能带回一些那种东西。这说得好。这很有趣。
That's interesting. I also heard rumors that they were going to do 3D support, which is interesting because Nintendo 3DS. I'll get it right. Have you seen one of these yet? Have you used one? I haven't used one, but I saw pictures of it. It looks pretty awesome. Have you actually stood in front of one, though?
这很有趣。我还听到传言说他们要做 3D 支持，这很有趣，因为任天堂 3DS。我会说对的。你见过其中一个了吗？你用过吗？我没用过，但我看过它的照片。看起来很棒。你真的站在它前面过吗？
No. I saw one in the store. I couldn't use it. It's really cool. No 3D glasses. You stand in front of it, and yeah, things pop out of the screen. It's pretty cool. I don't know how it would be long-term, but it's pretty awesome.
没有。我在店里看到过一个。我没法用。它真的很酷。不需要 3D 眼镜。你站在它前面，是的，东西会从屏幕里跳出来。这很酷。我不知道长期使用会怎样，但它非常棒。
So if I remember right, it uses several layers of LCD, right? And each one can be clear or a certain color. And so the layers give a parallax that creates the 3D illusion. Yeah, I think that's right. Something like that. And it's adjustable with a slider. Oh, really? Yeah, so you can kind of adjust how much 3D it is. I heard some people talking about some of the games are actually really useful
如果我没记错的话，它使用了几层 LCD，对吧？每一层都可以是透明的或某种颜色。所以这些层提供了产生 3D 错觉的视差。是的，我想是对的。类似那样的东西。而且它可以用滑块调节。哦，真的吗？是的，所以你可以调节 3D 的程度。我听到一些人说，有些游戏实际上非常有用，
because it helps you give that extra depth perception you need to be able to avoid a wall coming up or fly under something or walk around something. It's kind of cool. But Nintendo, with the 3DS, their whole thing is, right, oh, we're better, no 3D glasses needed. We're going to do this so that everybody can use it and not have to wear silly-looking 3D glasses. So it would be interesting if they decide to go with 3D glasses
因为它能给你提供所需的额外深度感知，让你能够避开迎面而来的墙壁，或者从某物下方飞过，或者绕过某物。这很酷。但任天堂，对于 3DS，他们的整个卖点是，对吧，哦，我们更好，不需要 3D 眼镜。我们要这样做，以便每个人都能使用它，而不必戴上看起来很傻的 3D 眼镜。所以如果他们决定使用 3D 眼镜，那会很有趣，
to kind of go back on themselves. Although it's not uncommon for companies to do that. Apple does that all the time. It would be a terrible idea to do this, and then their very next product does exactly that thing. Yeah, exactly. So there's going to be a Star Fox 3D on the 3DS. Remember Star Fox?
这有点走回头路。尽管公司这样做并不罕见。苹果一直这样做。做一个主意很糟糕，然后他们的下一个产品就完全做了那件事。是的，完全正确。所以 3DS 上会有一个《星际火狐 3D》。还记得《星际火狐》吗？
Yes. Oh, man. I think I might have to go and buy one right now. Oh, no, no, no. That would be kind of crazy. Yeah, but I heard it was going to be called a stream as well. But I remember, I don't remember what the Wii, the Wii had a different code name before that I actually kind of liked better.
是的。哦，天哪。我想我现在可能得去买一个了。哦，不，不，不。那会有点疯狂。是的，但我听说它也会被称为 Stream。但我记得，我不记得 Wii 在那之前有一个不同的代号，我其实更喜欢那个。
It was, oh, what was it? I liked it better than what Wii was, I remember. And then Wii came out and everybody was like making jokes about Wii. But now that, no, I kind of like it. Wii is kind of fun. It's Wii. I don't know, I kind of like saying it. Yeah, and the whole Wii would like to play, you know, advertising campaign.
它是，哦，是什么来着？我记得我比 Wii 更喜欢它。然后 Wii 出来了，每个人都在拿 Wii 开玩笑。但现在，不，我有点喜欢它。Wii 很有趣。它是 Wii。我不知道，我有点喜欢说它。是的，整个 Wii 想要玩，你知道，广告活动。
And the Miis, you make your Miis. Yep, yep. I kind of liked it. I think it was called the Revolution. That was the Nintendo Revolution, right? Before it was the Wii. Yeah, that's right, that's right. Yeah.
还有 Mii，你制作你的 Mii。没错，没错。我有点喜欢它。我想它叫 Revolution。那是任天堂 Revolution，对吧？在它成为 Wii 之前。是的，没错，没错。是的。
I guess maybe, now in hindsight, it kind of seems stupid. Oh well. The time has passed and my opinion has changed. So going from really high tech to somewhat low tech, another story here is about this Lego assembly line. Is that where they make Legos? No, this is actually somebody taking lego and building an assembly line out of lego what wait wait so they assemble legos with legos that's right is that
我想也许，现在回想起来，它看起来有点蠢。哦，好吧。时间已经过去，我的观点也变了。所以从高科技到某种低科技，这里的另一个故事是关于这个乐高装配线。那是他们制造乐高的地方吗？不，这实际上是有人拿乐高积木，用乐高搭建了一条装配线。等等，等等，所以他们用乐高组装乐高？没错，那是
right okay okay i gotta keep track of this it's like it's like meta okay hang on keep going all right keep going yeah i think this this as, you know, the first, like, reproductive organ that's ever been made out of Lego. Because now he's able to, if he can produce itself, then we have a complete species here of Lego. Uh-oh. I, for one, welcome our Lego overlords. That's right. So, yeah, you guys should definitely visit the blog and check this link out. Yeah, it has a killer video.
真的吗？好吧，好吧，我得跟上这个。这就像是元（meta），好吧，等等，继续。好的，继续。是的，我想这是第一个用乐高制造的生殖器官。因为现在他能够，如果它能自我复制，那么我们就拥有了一个完整的乐高物种。噢，糟糕。我个人欢迎我们的乐高霸主。没错。所以，是的，你们一定要访问博客并查看这个链接。是的，它有一个杀手级的视频。
It sounds like the big dog robot walking because all these different Mindstorm. Big dog's awesome. Yeah, all these different Mindstorm parts, axes. So can it rebuild itself? No. Or it just builds other things? Yeah, right now it's pretty simplistic. It only has four robot arms.
听起来像大狗机器人走路，因为所有这些不同的 Mindstorm。大狗很棒。是的，所有这些不同的 Mindstorm 部件，轴。所以它能重建自己吗？不能。或者它只是制造其他东西？是的，现在它非常简单。它只有四个机械臂。
But I think it can build these little cars. Oh, that's kind of cool. Yeah, it can build like a block. It can take Legos and build essentially a bigger Lego, like a macro Lego block by stacking several of these together. Yeah, I got interested recently in what I guess is called the RepRap, which is the idea of a replicating machine that can replicate itself. So it prints parts, and it prints parts for itself so it can make new itselfs.
但我认为它可以制造这些小车。哦，那很酷。是的，它可以制造一个积木。它可以拿乐高积木，通过堆叠几个积木，本质上制造一个更大的乐高，就像一个宏观乐高积木。是的，我最近对所谓的 RepRap 很感兴趣，这是一种可以自我复制的复制机器的想法。所以它打印零件，并为自己打印零件，这样它就可以制造新的自己。
Right. And then that drives down costs, because if you can do it perfectly, you can end up making them really cheap, because then you end up having lots and lots of things that can make more of those things, up making them really cheap. Because then you end up having lots and lots of things that can make more of those things. And, you know, it becomes really awesome. And it's really clever because they have parts that at this point in time they're not able to print. So, like, circuit boards, metal rods, screws, things like that. Or things that are economically prohibitive to print.
没错。然后这会降低成本，因为如果你能完美地做到这一点，你最终可以制造出非常便宜的东西，因为你最终会有很多很多可以制造更多那些东西的东西，最终制造出非常便宜的东西。因为你最终会有很多很多可以制造更多那些东西的东西。而且，你知道，它变得非常棒。而且它非常聪明，因为他们有目前无法打印的零件。比如，电路板、金属杆、螺丝之类的东西。或者在经济上禁止打印的东西。
And then they call those things vitamins, which is things your body needs but can't make. So I thought it was kind of clever. And it's really interesting. Maybe I'll have to talk about that sometime. And then they call those things vitamins, which is things your body needs but can't make. So I thought it was kind of clever. And it's really interesting. Maybe I'll have to talk about that sometime. But, yeah, this sounds like not quite the same thing because it can't make its own self out of Legos, which would be even cooler. But maybe it's a step in that direction. Maybe somebody will inspire it and make its own bootstrapping Lego factory. And then one day giant Lego robots will appear outside of our house and knock knock knock we've come to take over give us your children uh-oh that would be good but yeah
然后他们把这些东西称为维生素，也就是你的身体需要但无法制造的东西。所以我认为这很聪明。而且它非常有趣。也许我以后得谈谈这个。然后他们把这些东西称为维生素，也就是你的身体需要但无法制造的东西。所以我认为这很聪明。而且它非常有趣。也许我以后得谈谈这个。但是，是的，这听起来不太一样，因为它不能用乐高制造它自己，那会更酷。但也许这是朝着那个方向迈出的一步。也许有人会受到启发，制造出自己的引导式乐高工厂。然后有一天，巨大的乐高机器人会出现在我们家门外，敲敲敲，我们来接管了，把你们的孩子交出来。噢，糟糕，那会很好，但是的，
you know it's really interesting how with lego mind storms you can do just about anything um you know it's uh i believe lego mind storms it's its own language, right? Yeah, now I haven't, but I know that they have, in typical over-the-top nerd fashion, I think people do a lot with it, but I think originally it came out, and I remember it being a visual language, so you actually had little parts that you would drop on for an if statement or a loop, and you could drop those little blocks down and then it would go to the little brain the controller brick or i'm not sure what their term is for it and and it would control the other legos but now i think they even have the ability and then they had a
你知道，用乐高 Mindstorms 你几乎可以做任何事情，这非常有趣，嗯，你知道，我相信乐高 Mindstorms 有它自己的语言，对吧？是的，现在我还没有，但我知道他们有，以典型的书呆子方式，我想人们用它做了很多事情，但我记得它最初出来时，我记得它是一种可视化语言，所以你实际上有小部件，你可以放下它们作为 if 语句或循环，你可以放下那些小积木，然后它会去那个小大脑，控制器砖，或者我不确定他们对它的称呼是什么，它会控制其他乐高积木，但现在我想他们甚至有能力，然后他们有
language you could write in but i think people even have where you can write and see now yeah according to wikipedia you can write in java and see nowstorms, yeah. And so this is really interesting that... So if you listen to our first podcast, then you'll have the language C under your belt. You'll know what you're doing, and then you can go program a Lego factory to replicate itself. Yeah, if you do that, definitely let us know. We will have you on the show
你可以编写的语言，但我想人们甚至有你可以编写 C 的地方。现在，是的，根据维基百科，你现在可以用 Java 和 C 编写 Mindstorms。所以这非常有趣……所以如果你听了我们的第一个播客，那么你就会掌握 C 语言。你会知道你在做什么，然后你可以去编程一个乐高工厂来复制它自己。是的，如果你这样做，一定要告诉我们。我们会让你上节目，
if you can build a self-replicating Lego factory. That would be epic. Especially if you learn about C from us. Oh, yeah factory that would be epic especially if you learn about c from us oh yeah that would be even better yeah yeah or tell your friends and maybe they'll learn about c and then go do this yeah and maybe a year or two or three or four so yeah i mean a lot of these robotics problems are problems that actually you'll encounter like you guys who are in computer science at university or at high school uh you know, something like path planning. You know, when you do path planning,
如果你能制造一个自我复制的乐高工厂。那将是史诗级的。特别是如果你从我们这里学习 C 语言的话。哦，是的，工厂，那将是史诗级的，特别是如果你从我们这里学习 C 语言的话。哦，是的，那会更好。是的，是的，或者告诉你的朋友，也许他们会学习 C 语言，然后去这样做。是的，也许一两年或三年或四年。所以，是的，我的意思是，很多这些机器人问题实际上是你会在大学或高中的计算机科学中遇到的问题，你知道，比如路径规划。你知道，当你做路径规划时，
you might look at just a little, you know, circle in a maze trying to get through this maze. And you might not be thinking about real applications. You might think, well, when in real life am I ever going to be in a maze? There was that one time. A minute time? Oh, man, that was rough. I really wish we had a laptop there to run for our lives but i should have studied better that a star algorithm yeah that's right
你可能只是看着迷宫里的一个小圆圈试图穿过这个迷宫。你可能没有在想实际的应用。你可能会想，在现实生活中我什么时候会进入迷宫？有那么一次。一分钟？哦，天哪，那太艰难了。我真希望我们当时有一台笔记本电脑来逃命，但我应该更好地学习那个 A* 算法。是的，没错，
but um you know robotics the way the robot arm moves is actually path planning so you have the robot arm sort of the positions that it wants to be in as sort of the goal the exit of the maze and where it is now as the start of the maze and sometimes you know it has to be in as sort of the goal the exit of the maze and where it is now as the start of the maze and sometimes you know it has to move to the right so that it can swing to the left without hitting a wall with a different joint yeah exactly kind of like an octopus arm you know so um uh there's an example of where you know algorithms that you see in computer science school that you think you know who's ever going to use this? And then you find out later in life, oh, everyone uses this, you know.
但是，嗯，你知道，机器人，机器人手臂移动的方式实际上就是路径规划，所以你有机器人手臂想要处于的位置作为目标，迷宫的出口，以及它现在所在的位置作为迷宫的起点，有时，你知道，它必须向右移动，这样它才能向左摆动，而不会用不同的关节撞到墙壁。是的，完全正确，有点像章鱼手臂，你知道，所以，嗯，这是一个例子，你知道，你在计算机科学学校看到的算法，你认为，你知道，谁会用这个？然后你后来在生活中发现，哦，每个人都用这个，你知道。
Plus, let's admit it. Robots are awesome. Yep. Robots make anything cooler. I think every comp sci class should have a Lego Mindstorm. And lasers. That's right. And, well, I was going to give a Portal 2 spoiler.
另外，让我们承认吧。机器人很棒。没错。机器人让任何东西都更酷。我认为每门计算机科学课都应该有一个乐高 Mindstorm。还有激光。没错。而且，嗯，我本来要给《传送门 2》剧透的。
No, stop. Stop, stop, stop. We'll just stop with robots and lasers. And portals. Okay. I haven't played it, so if I give out any spoilers, it's completely accidental. That's right. So what is your tool of the buy week? So on robots and
不，停下。停下，停下，停下。我们就停在机器人和激光上吧。还有传送门。好吧。我还没玩过，所以如果我剧透了，那完全是偶然的。没错。那么你本周的工具是什么？所以关于机器人和
building things and atoms as opposed to bits, my tool of the week goes a little bit different with the Texas Instruments MSP 430. Don't you love it when companies name things cleverly? Yeah, I was going to say
制造东西和原子而不是比特，我本周的工具有点不同，是德州仪器的 MSP 430。你不喜欢公司巧妙地命名东西吗？是的，我本来想说
now I know exactly what that is. Yeah, don't you? I'm so glad. That's just the mind meld that's going on here between ti and us um so so this is kind of interesting um i've used before another product that's kind of in the same vein as this called the arduino and the arduino is an at mega chip with a bootloader and a little board that comes with it and for i think it's like 20 and an awesome interface and they made it all open hardware and it's pretty cool and you can use it to do all sorts of interesting things and there's a great community that was built up around and i really like arduino people used to do a lot of things um but kind of similar to the lego mind storms
现在我知道那是什么了。是的，你不喜欢吗？我很高兴。这就是 TI 和我们之间正在进行的思维融合。嗯，所以这很有趣。嗯，我以前用过另一个产品，和这个属于同一类，叫 Arduino，Arduino 是一个带有引导加载程序和随附小板的 ATmega 芯片，我想大概 20 美元，还有一个很棒的界面，他们把它做成了开源硬件，非常酷，你可以用它做各种有趣的事情，而且围绕它建立了一个很棒的社区，我真的很喜欢 Arduino，人们过去用它做很多事情，嗯，但有点像乐高 Mindstorms，
where people use stuff for more than it's intended to and kind of do a lot of work instead of picking the right tool for the job or learning the next thing they use what they have and do really creative but if all you have is a hammer everything becomes a nail right so um people use arduino to do a lot of things that um are really clever and cool but it could probably be done easily more easily or cheaper because one of the things is even though arduino is cheap at twenty dollars or so depending on what version you get um it's not something you want to leave in a project or leave in something or you know because it's twenty dollars i mean that's kind of you know i don't want to just go wasting twenty dollars all the time and so the texas instruments response to that is to try to build up a community around some of their products
人们把东西用于超出其预期的用途，并做了很多工作，而不是选择合适的工具来完成工作或学习下一件事，他们使用他们拥有的东西并做出了非常创造性的事情，但如果你只有一把锤子，一切都会变成钉子，对吧？所以，嗯，人们使用 Arduino 做很多事情，嗯，非常聪明和酷，但它可能可以更容易或更便宜地完成，因为其中一件事是，即使 Arduino 很便宜，大约 20 美元左右，取决于你买的版本，它不是你想留在项目里或留在某样东西里的东西，或者你知道，因为它是 20 美元，我的意思是，那有点，你知道，我不想一直浪费 20 美元，所以德州仪器的回应是尝试围绕他们的一些产品建立一个社区，
and and they do you know they're like you know dominant in the dsp market um for industry and so they say how do we get to these consumers because these consumers these people in college they will eventually work in companies and they'll be able to do stuff like you know themselves and plus these you know chips a lot of times are very cheap for them to make so they can sell a kit for it, you know, more power to them, it's awesome. And so this MSP430 thing that they have now, the launch pad, oh, I guess this will actually be my tool that we use, the MSP430 launch pad, is kind of an Arduino competitor that sells for $4.30 shipped to your door, you know, everything included.
而且他们做到了，你知道，他们在 DSP 市场占据主导地位，为工业服务，所以他们说我们如何接触这些消费者？因为这些消费者，这些大学生，他们最终会在公司工作，他们将能够做一些事情，比如，你知道，他们自己做，而且这些芯片很多时候对他们来说制造非常便宜，所以他们可以卖一个套件，你知道，权力归他们，这很棒。所以他们现在拥有的这个 MSP430，LaunchPad，哦，我想这实际上将是我使用的工具，MSP430 LaunchPad，有点像 Arduino 的竞争对手，售价 4.30 美元，送到你家门口，你知道，包括所有东西。
That's awesome. So I can't recall when i bought mine but i think it even had a usb connector in it so pretty much you have one of these yeah so i have i have one of these um i've not done too much with it but it is pretty cool oh it says 430 plus shipping maybe that's changed but i don't i don't think shipping's very much it's pretty small but it's a pretty nice kit. And it's interesting because at only $4.30, a little easier to leave that in a project now. And it's not exactly the same as Arduino, but it's kind of similar. And, you know, we do a lot of open source tools for the free things for the tool of the week. But this is something that's
那太棒了。所以我记不起我什么时候买的了，但我认为它甚至有一个 USB 连接器，所以基本上你有一个这个。是的，所以我有一个这个。嗯，我没用它做太多事情，但它确实很酷。哦，它说 430 加运费，也许那变了，但我认为运费不多，它很小，但它是一个非常好的套件。而且这很有趣，因为只有 4.30 美元，现在把那个留在项目里更容易了。而且它和 Arduino 不完全一样，但有点类似。而且，你知道，我们为本周的工具做了很多开源工具，免费的东西。但这是
really cheap and really cool because I remember being in, you know, high school and being interested in electronics and making things out of magazines. There's not a lot of that today at that level, but there's a lot of stuff on the internet today that we didn't have when we were growing up. And so something like this, when you're younger, your parents don't necessarily mind giving you $5 for something or whatever. And then use their permission and then maybe they'll let you, they can put in their credit card information for you so that you can get one of these.
非常便宜且非常酷的东西，因为我记得在高中时，对电子产品感兴趣，并用杂志制作东西。今天在那个层面上没有很多那种东西，但今天互联网上有很多我们成长时没有的东西。所以像这样的东西，当你年轻时，你的父母不一定介意给你 5 美元买东西之类的。然后使用他们的许可，然后也许他们会让你，他们可以为你输入他们的信用卡信息，这样你就可以得到其中一个。
But that's pretty cool for $4.30. There's a lot of stuff you can learn with this. Writing code in C, actually, it might do C++, but they give you a version of their Code Composer, which is their product that you use for like the higher end dsps that that you know people use that there are jobs and stuff and they provide that and you're able to use it to write c code to do stuff like you know play with instead of just making a loop that prints hello world that's kind of cool but yeah i don't know there's something different about writing
但对于4.30美元来说，这真的很酷。你可以通过它学到很多东西。实际上，它可以用C语言编写代码，可能也支持C++，但他们提供了一个版本的Code Composer，这是他们的产品，通常用于人们在工作中使用的那些高端DSP。他们提供了这个工具，你可以用它来编写C代码，做一些事情，比如玩玩看，而不仅仅是写一个打印“Hello World”的循环，这很酷，但确实，我不知道，编写代码有些不同的地方。
instead of print hello word turn le toggle led like it's just cool it's just nice to see something in the real world other than your screen you know doing awesome things um hooking up a servo and making watching it move or you know affecting things it's it's fun it's i don't know i'm kind of into hardware i know you're a little bit more uh high level software than i am but yeah i wish you know it's something I want to get more into I just I'm kind of ignorant on it right now but I am really interested how does it so I might show the ignorance here but let's say you have a servo that you want to communicate with yep do you have to buy a TI servo or I mean is there a library or how does this work so um on the MSP430 there probably
不仅仅是打印“Hello World”，而是切换LED灯，看到现实世界中除了屏幕之外的东西在做很棒的事情，这真的很酷。比如连接一个伺服电机，看着它移动，或者影响其他事物，这很有趣。我不知道，我比较喜欢硬件，我知道你比我更偏向于高层软件，但我希望，你知道，这是我想深入了解的东西。我现在对它还比较无知，但我真的很感兴趣。它是怎么工作的？我可能会在这里表现出无知，但假设你有一个想要通信的伺服电机，是的，你必须购买TI的伺服电机吗？或者说，有没有库，或者这是怎么运作的？所以，嗯，在MSP430上可能
is example code out there if not not, it's not that hard. But no, so what happens is servos are controlled by something called pulse width modulation, which this is a programming show, so maybe this is out of context. But oh, wow, we're going to learn something new today. Yeah. So pulse width modulation, which is given a set, and I'm going to flub this up for any electrical engineers listening, so tune out now, please, andume this in about three to four minutes.
有现成的示例代码，如果没有，也不难。但不是的，伺服电机是通过一种叫做脉冲宽度调制（PWM）的东西来控制的，这是一个编程节目，所以这可能有点离题了。但是，哦，哇，我们今天又要学新东西了。是的。所以脉冲宽度调制，它是给定的，如果任何电气工程师在听的话，我可能会把它讲错，所以现在请调台，请在大约三到四分钟后再回来。
This is like an anti-spoiler. It's like we know we're not going to spoil anything good on electrical engineering. Yes. So the idea is you've got a set rate. So let's say, you know, every one hertz you're going to have a cycle. Once per second, just to make it easy. It would never be that long because that would be too much delay between signals. But so you have one second cycle rate so
这就像是一个反剧透。就像我们知道我们不会剧透任何关于电气工程的好东西一样。是的。所以这个想法是，你有一个设定的速率。所以假设，你知道，每一赫兹你都会有一个周期。每秒一次，为了简单起见。它永远不会那么长，因为信号之间的延迟会太长。但是，所以你有一个一秒的周期速率，所以
the servo will say for instance center position it will be a 50 on 50 off so if 50 of the pulse width so that time of one second if for 500 milliseconds the pulse is high and the rest is low it's going to be centered in the center position of the servo because the servo goes from a plus degrees to a minus degrees. It normally doesn't do continuous rotation. If you make the signal less than 50%, you normally have it centered in your window, so it's a little hump in the middle. So if you have it for 250 milliseconds, that, depending on the servo, could be full over left.
伺服电机，例如在中心位置，它将是50%开启，50%关闭。所以如果脉冲宽度的50%，即一秒钟的时间里，如果脉冲高电平持续500毫秒，其余时间为低电平，它就会居中在伺服电机的中心位置，因为伺服电机的运动范围是从正度数到负度数。它通常不做连续旋转。如果你让信号小于50%，你通常会让它在窗口中居中，所以中间会有一个小凸起。所以如果你让它持续250毫秒，根据伺服电机的不同，这可能是完全向左。
And if you have it for 750 milliseconds, that could be full over right. And so varying that width of the pulse allows you to control the position of the servo. And then the servo holds its position once it's there by itself. It knows if you keep sending that pulse, it knows how to stay there. And if somebody tries to go move it or push against it, it'll try to move back to the right place. So it's a closed loop thing in itself. And that pulse width is a way of communicating to it.
如果你让它持续750毫秒，那可能是完全向右。因此，改变脉冲的宽度可以让你控制伺服电机的位置。然后伺服电机一旦到达那里，就会自己保持位置。它知道如果你继续发送那个脉冲，它就知道如何保持在那里。如果有人试图去移动它或推它，它会试图移回正确的位置。所以它本身就是一个闭环系统。而那个脉冲宽度就是与它通信的一种方式。
So in that way, you can buy any Pulse Width modulated servo, and it'll work. Now, there are newer servos which communicate, for instance, like on I2C or something, which is another protocol, so it wouldn't have to be specific. But you just kind of got to know. And other people are out there doing this stuff. And you can buy servos really cheap online. We're talking like $1, $2, $3, $4 five dollars you know i see a lot of servos for five dollars they're not great servos but you can make a move and do little things and um yeah so a lot of times you can find sample
所以通过这种方式，你可以购买任何脉冲宽度调制的伺服电机，它都能工作。现在，有一些更新的伺服电机可以通过例如I2C或其他协议进行通信，所以它不一定非要是特定的。但你只需要了解一下。其他人也在做这些事情。你可以在网上买到非常便宜的伺服电机。我们说的是1美元、2美元、3美元、4美元、5美元，你知道，我看到很多5美元的伺服电机，它们不是很好的伺服电机，但你可以让它们移动并做一些小事情，嗯，所以很多时候你可以找到示例
code to do it i don't know if the msp430 has but a lot of the dsp chips have a library set up to do pulse width modulation where you basically just say my cycle length is this time and my current pulse width should be this and then it handles all the rest of it for you oh so it's got its own like wild true kind of thing going on there and it's in hardware so that you don't have to waste cpu cycles sitting there because if it was using a cpu you kind of spent a lot of time trying to sit there managing making sure it's right this way you can kind of tell the hardware go do this and then it just sits there and does it for you cool that's awesome yeah i want to make i want to just just get started making really simple things like something that would like unscrew a bottle you know bottle cap
代码来做这件事。我不知道MSP430是否有，但很多DSP芯片都有一个库来做脉冲宽度调制，你基本上只需要说我的周期长度是这个时间，我当前的脉冲宽度应该是这个，然后它就会为你处理剩下的所有事情。哦，所以它有自己的那种“while true”循环在运行，而且是在硬件中，这样你就不用浪费CPU周期坐在那里，因为如果它使用CPU，你可能花了很多时间坐在那里管理，确保它是正确的。这样你就可以告诉硬件去执行这个，然后它就坐在那里为你做这件事。酷，太棒了。是的，我想开始做一些非常简单的东西，比如像可以拧开瓶盖的东西
or something like that and uh get started so maybe i'll pick up one of these launch pads yeah so um launch pad is my tool of the bi-week and yours nice so my tool of the bye week. And yours? Nice. So my tool of the bye week is along similar lines, along the lines of getting into hardware. And so the tool is SketchUp, Google SketchUp, which SketchUp by itself is just a 3D modeling tool, but it doesn't do texturing. And it's not focused on texturing as most tools are and on authoring, you know, 3D content for, you know, video games or for movies. SketchUp is about drafting and it's about sort of designing something at a high level. So that's why if you see SketchUp, you know, models, they'll often look very flat. And that's because what you're seeing is what's the focus is really on the geometry of the model and not so much on how it actually looks.
或者类似的东西，然后开始动手。所以也许我会买一个这样的LaunchPad。是的，所以LaunchPad是我双周的工具，你的也是。不错。所以我的双周工具。你的呢？不错。所以我的双周工具是沿着类似的思路，沿着进入硬件的思路。所以这个工具是SketchUp，Google SketchUp，SketchUp本身只是一个3D建模工具，但它不做纹理处理。它不像大多数工具那样专注于纹理和创作，你知道，为视频游戏或电影创作3D内容。SketchUp是关于绘图的，它是关于在高层设计某种东西的。这就是为什么如果你看到SketchUp模型，它们通常看起来非常平坦。这是因为你所看到的是，重点确实是在模型的几何形状上，而不是它看起来如何。
You're not going to find a ray tracer. You're not going to find lighting and mirrors and all these fancy things that you might in RenderMan, which makes Shrek in those movies. But if you want to just rapidly prototype, it has an extremely slick user interface and it knows that because it's a design tool, that the geometry is
你找不到光线追踪器。你找不到照明、镜子和所有那些你在RenderMan（制作《怪物史莱克》等电影的软件）中可能找到的花哨东西。但如果你想快速原型设计，它有一个极其流畅的用户界面，而且它知道因为这是一个设计工具，所以几何形状
not going to be very complex. You're not going to try to model someone's face in SketchUp. So it lets you mess with the different vertices and different geometry at a low level, knowing that you're not going to be dealing with millions of these objects. And because of that, it gives you a lot of flexibility.
不会非常复杂。你不会试图在SketchUp中模拟某人的脸。所以它让你在低层处理不同的顶点和不同的几何形状，知道你不会处理数百万个这样的对象。正因为如此，它给了你很大的灵活性。
So SketchUp actually integrates with something called the Thingamatic, which is done by MakerBot. And you can buy this Thingamatic kit, and it'll actually work in tandem with SketchUp to produce 3D, I guess, lithographs. Is that the right word? Printed. Yeah, basically 3D, like real 3D models. Yeah, it extrudes little bits of plastic. Yeah, so you can, in SketchUp, you can make a model of uh you know a sphere or
所以SketchUp实际上与一个叫做Thing-O-Matic的东西集成在一起，这是由MakerBot完成的。你可以购买这个Thing-O-Matic套件，它实际上会与SketchUp协同工作，产生3D，我想是平版印刷？这是正确的词吗？打印。是的，基本上是3D，就像真正的3D模型。是的，它挤出一点点塑料。是的，所以你可以在SketchUp中制作一个球体模型，或者
try and like grow your you know make them design a model of your hand or or a model of a little spaceship and uh you can export your sketchup model to maker bot and it will actually construct it in 3d out of a plastic resin yeah so i I wasn't paying attention that this was your tool of the week. So when earlier I was talking about the RepRap, that this is kind of the same idea. RepRap is similar to the MakerBot. It's not the open source version of the MakerBot, but an earlier version of the MakerBot, something that... How do you spell it?
尝试像生长你的，你知道，让他们设计一个你的手的模型，或者一个小飞船的模型，你可以把你的SketchUp模型导出到MakerBot，它实际上会用塑料树脂在3D中构建它。是的，所以我没注意这是你本周的工具。所以当我早些时候谈论RepRap时，这和那个想法是一样的。RepRap类似于MakerBot。它不是MakerBot的开源版本，而是MakerBot的早期版本，某种……你怎么拼写它？
RepRap. R-E-P-R-A-P. Okay. And so this is one that is, you know, with kind of the intention of bootstrapping itself that I was talking about. It does kind of something similar to the MakerBot, though, where it prints things out of what,
RepRap。R-E-P-R-A-P。好的。所以这是一个，你知道，带着某种自举意图的工具，我刚才提到的。它确实做了和MakerBot类似的事情，它用什么打印东西，
I guess it's rods of plastic string, goes into a little extruder, and it puts little dots at a single layer. Then it moves the platform down or moves the extruder up and then places another set of little dots. And slowly, you know, layer by layer, it builds up. So, kind of like an inkjet printer. But instead of, you know, the paper moving out, the head moves around and then the platform
我想是塑料绳的杆子，进入一个小挤出机，它在单层上放置小点。然后它向下移动平台或向上移动挤出机，然后放置另一组小点。然后慢慢地，你知道，一层一层地，它建立起来。所以，有点像喷墨打印机。但不是，你知道，纸张移动，而是头在周围移动，然后平台
and head separate and then it prints again, slowly building up the structure. Nice. So, interesting. I don't know if you've seen this before, but, you know, the Thing-O-Matic is a 3D printer. head separate and then it prints again slowly building up the structure nice um so interesting i don't know if you've seen this before but you know the thing-o-matic is a 3d printer and then the thingiverse which is thingiverse.com is a collection of 3d models a lot of which have been done in google sketchup yep and people put these things up here, open source, you know, repository of them. And then they have it so you can print it with your MakerBot or with your RepRap or sometimes with a laser cutter and make these things that other people have made
和头分开，然后它再次打印，慢慢建立结构。不错。所以，很有趣。我不知道你以前是否见过这个，但是，你知道，Thing-O-Matic是一个3D打印机。头分开，然后它再次打印，慢慢建立结构。不错，嗯，所以很有趣。我不知道你以前是否见过这个，但是，你知道，Thing-O-Matic是一个3D打印机，然后Thingiverse，也就是thingiverse.com，是一个3D模型集合，其中很多是在Google SketchUp中完成的，是的，人们把这些东西放在这里，开源，你知道，它们的存储库。然后他们有它，所以你可以用你的MakerBot或你的RepRap打印它，或者有时用激光切割机，制作这些其他人制作的东西
and make them yourself. So the idea that, you know, one day in the future, I want a coffee mug. I don't have a coffee mug. You just go over to your printer and you go to, you know, Amazon.com or maybe you go to one of these Thingiverse, a free one, and you download a free coffee mug and then it just prints it on your printer. And then five minutes later you come and there's your coffee mug ready to use. Yeah, I think this is a really exciting time for us, you know, computer nerds because, you know, for example, I wanted to make a PDA that was completely open source. And it was a really big pain. I had to get the
并自己制作它们。所以这个想法是，你知道，未来有一天，我想要一个咖啡杯。我没有咖啡杯。你只需要走到你的打印机前，你去，你知道，Amazon.com，或者也许你去这些Thingiverse中的一个，一个免费的，你下载一个免费的咖啡杯，然后它就在你的打印机上打印出来。然后五分钟后你过来，你的咖啡杯就准备好使用了。是的，我认为这对我们这些电脑极客来说是一个非常令人兴奋的时代，因为，你知道，例如，我想制作一个完全开源的PDA。这真的很痛苦。我必须得到
circuit board. I had to get a little LCD display. I had to make those two talk to each other. I had to write my own driver for the LCD display. I had to get a version of Linux, blah, blah, blah, so on and so forth. But then once I had done all that, you know, software engineering work, I ended up using Lego. I had to build a case for my PDA and not knowing anything about hardware or woodworking or anything at the time, I used Lego and made this giant PDA that barely fits in my pocket, but plays Dwarf Fortress out of Lego and gumsticks board and lcd so but now the technology has come so far that for you know it's still it's still a little expensive the thingamatic is thirteen hundred dollars and the other one is uh the rep wrap is what around 800 yeah i mean it just depends on what level of kit you get but i think yeah all up once you pay for everything, it's going to be about that. But, yeah, for about $1,500, you could have something which constructs the shell of whatever you want.
电路板。我必须得到一个小LCD显示屏。我必须让那两个东西互相交谈。我必须为LCD显示屏编写我自己的驱动程序。我必须得到一个Linux版本，等等等等。但一旦我完成了所有这些，你知道，软件工程工作，我最终使用了乐高。我必须为我的PDA建造一个外壳，当时对硬件或木工一无所知，我使用了乐高，制作了这个巨大的PDA，几乎放不进我的口袋，但用乐高和Gumstix板以及LCD玩《矮人要塞》。所以，但现在技术已经发展到，你知道，它仍然，它仍然有点贵，Thing-O-Matic是1300美元，另一个是，嗯，RepRap大约是800美元。是的，我的意思是这取决于你得到什么级别的套件。但我认为，是的，一旦你支付了所有费用，大约就是那个价格。但是，是的，大约1500美元，你就可以拥有一个可以构建你想要的任何东西的外壳的东西。
The electrical component, you can get that for $4, as Patrick showed, and the different servos and motors and sensors that make up, you know, that part of your design. But we're in a position where you can prototype just about anything as a hobbyist. I mean, if you need it to be stainless steel and you do arc welding, well, you might still be out of luck. But, you know, you could do just about anything nowadays, and I think that's really exciting. Yeah, and I've tried my hand at things like SketchUp and others and found I'm pretty terrible at it.
电气组件，你可以以4美元的价格得到它，正如Patrick展示的那样，还有构成你设计那部分的各种伺服电机、马达和传感器。但我们处于一个可以作为业余爱好者原型设计几乎任何东西的位置。我的意思是，如果你需要它是不锈钢的，并且你做弧焊，好吧，你可能仍然不走运。但是，你知道，你现在几乎可以做任何事情，我认为这真的很令人兴奋。是的，我也尝试过像SketchUp和其他东西，发现我真的很糟糕。
Yeah, me too. But what's cool is some of the people doing this printing are writing computer programs to make the files to print. So I saw one guy the other day ran Conway's Game of Life and let it play out over a whole bunch of iterations and then kind of kept a history of everywhere where it went and printed out a 3d model of like a representation of a run of game of life and um that was kind of cool or you know procedurally generating a 3d model and then printing that out so you know like a fractal generator or um like a what is it sarah impitsky's gasket right in 3d and then that out. So if you're really nerdy but are terrible at drawing stuff and making stuff on SketchUp, then you can write programs to make the models that then your printer can print.
是的，我也是。但很酷的是，一些做这种打印的人正在编写计算机程序来制作打印文件。所以我前几天看到一个人运行了康威的生命游戏，让它在很多次迭代中运行，然后保留了它所到之处的历史，并打印出了一个3D模型，就像生命游戏运行的表示，嗯，那很酷，或者，你知道，程序化生成一个3D模型，然后打印出来。所以，你知道，像分形生成器，或者，嗯，像什么，谢尔宾斯基垫片，对吧，在3D中，然后打印出来。所以，如果你真的很书呆子，但画东西和在SketchUp上制作东西很糟糕，那么你可以编写程序来制作模型，然后你的打印机就可以打印出来。
Yeah, and Patrick made another good point earlier, which is both SketchUp and MakerBot and probably the RepRap, too, have a library of existing models. In fact, SketchUp has a massive, massive database. And you can get everything from buildings, famous buildings, you know, completely modeled in SketchUp, all the way down to, like, you know, a model of a hand. You can get different, like, I don't know, tools. You get those scissors that, you know, you can download just the model instead of having to make it yourself yeah can i print a house to live in maybe i don't think you could print a duplicate of your house though because your house has the printer in it and you would
是的，Patrick早些时候提出了另一个很好的观点，那就是SketchUp和MakerBot，可能还有RepRap，都有一个现有模型库。事实上，SketchUp有一个巨大的、巨大的数据库。你可以得到从建筑物、著名建筑物，你知道，完全在SketchUp中建模，一直到，像，你知道，手的模型。你可以得到不同的，像，我不知道，工具。你可以得到那些剪刀，你知道，你可以下载模型，而不是必须自己制作它。是的，我可以打印一个房子住吗？也许，我不认为你可以打印你房子的副本，因为你的房子里有打印机，你将
have to print the print of my house i think this was an xkcd. That's right. Uh-oh. The model would have to be in the model. Would you have to be in the model? No! Uh-oh. So don't model perfectly every detail of your house. That's right. And then try to print it.
不得不打印我房子的打印件。我想这是xkcd里的。没错。噢噢。模型必须在模型里。你必须在模型里吗？不！噢噢。所以不要完美地模拟你房子的每一个细节。没错。然后试着打印它。
Yeah, that would fail. Or model it. Yeah, bad idea. Yeah. So I'm going to give a shameless plug here to Endless Forms, which is close enough to what we were talking about but endlessforms.com is a website that's run from a couple of colleagues of mine out of cornell and this is a evolutionary computation program for generating three-dimensional art so uh i don't
是的，那会失败。或者模拟它。是的，坏主意。是的。所以我在这里要厚颜无耻地宣传一下Endless Forms，这和我们谈论的内容很接近，但endlessforms.com是一个网站，由我在康奈尔的几个同事运营，这是一个用于生成三维艺术的进化计算程序，所以，嗯，我
really know how to describe this but basically you start on there and it just has these random geometries of different circles and patterns and you can kind of see what they look excuse me what they look like in 3d and then uh you kind of you have you you pick from this population like oh i like okay okay so i'm here now and i see one that says mushroom so what do i do so what you're looking at when you go on Endless Forms, these are the top-rated forms that other people have made. So they've evolved them, or they've made them? That's right.
真的不知道怎么描述这个，但基本上你在上面开始，它只是有这些不同圆圈和图案的随机几何形状，你可以看到它们看起来，对不起，它们在3D中看起来是什么样子，然后，嗯，你有点，你从这个群体中选择，像“哦，我喜欢，好的，好的，所以我现在在这里，我看到一个写着蘑菇的”，所以我该怎么做？所以当你去Endless Forms时，你看到的是其他人制作的评分最高的形状。所以他们进化了它们，或者他们制作了它们？没错。
So you click on Start Anew. It's going to give you a set of individuals. You pick some parents, and you can mate them and see what their baby would look like. Interesting. Oh, okay. So it's giving me a bunch of random ones. Right. look like interesting oh okay so these are just giving me a bunch of random ones right and so the hope is that in the same way as you know the fast line catches the prey and natural evolution
所以你点击“重新开始”。它会给你一组个体。你选择一些父母，你可以让它们交配，看看它们的后代会是什么样子。有趣。哦，好的。所以它给了我一堆随机的。对。看起来很有趣。哦，好的，所以这些只是给了我一堆随机的，对吧？所以希望是，就像，你知道，快线捕捉猎物和自然进化一样，
survival of the fittest propagates in the same way you know that the shapes that you find the most pleasing or the most amiable for this session will start to propagate and you'll end up you know with your own species of 3d shape so these guys are going to be at the gecko conference this year showing off their their forms so if you have some time go to endlessforms.com and generate some cool things and they will add them to the to the display section at the conference. Interesting. Yeah. Although it's kind of interesting that all the popular ones are ones that resemble real-life objects.
适者生存以同样的方式传播，你知道，你觉得最令人愉悦或最适合这次会议的形状将开始传播，你最终会，你知道，拥有你自己的3D形状物种。所以这些家伙今年将在Gecko会议上展示他们的形式，所以如果你有时间，去endlessforms.com生成一些很酷的东西，他们会将它们添加到会议的展示部分。有趣。是的。虽然很有趣的是，所有流行的都是那些类似于现实生活中物体的。
Yeah, it is. It's sort of... As opposed to things that are... You know, you would have thought people would have been interested in things that are like, oh, that's clever, but new or different. Yeah, yeah, it's surprising that... You know, I think people are, at this point, yeah it's surprising that you know i think people are at this point since it's so early people are just happy that it can generate things that look like other things well cool that's cool all right and you know you could uh in theory if they give you the model
是的，确实是。这有点……而不是那些……你知道，你本以为人们会对那些像“哦，那很聪明，但新颖或不同”的东西感兴趣。是的，是的，令人惊讶的是……你知道，我认为人们，在这一点上，是的，令人惊讶的是，你知道，我认为人们在这一点上，因为还很早，人们只是很高兴它能生成看起来像其他东西的东西。好吧，酷，那很酷。好的，你知道，你可以，理论上，如果他们给你模型，
which i think they do you can uh import that into sketchup and then export that into the Thingamatic format, and then print it on a 3D printer. Ooh, that's cool. Yeah, good stuff. We better be careful, because if you print something sentient, we could all be in trouble. Yeah, bad news. Bad news. Or if you print a Klein bottle, it might just be stuck in an infinite loop. Ah, no, that would be terrible.
我想他们会给的，你可以，嗯，导入到SketchUp中，然后导出到Thing-O-Matic格式，然后在一个3D打印机上打印出来。噢，那很酷。是的，好东西。我们最好小心点，因为如果你打印出有知觉的东西，我们都可能有麻烦。是的，坏消息。坏消息。或者如果你打印一个克莱因瓶，它可能只是陷入无限循环。啊，不，那太糟糕了。
Yeah. All right, so I think that ties us up for our tools of the bye week. Cool. So I think we're going to be talking about MATLAB slash Octave this week. So why don't we start off talking about MATLAB, since that's the first of our pair here. What does MATLAB stand for? Yeah, so MATLAB stands for Matrix Laboratory. And so MATLAB is an interpreted language,
是的。好的，所以我认为这结束了我们双周工具的讨论。酷。所以我认为我们这周要谈论MATLAB斜杠Octave。那么我们为什么不先谈谈MATLAB，因为这是我们这对中的第一个。MATLAB代表什么？是的，所以MATLAB代表Matrix Laboratory（矩阵实验室）。所以MATLAB是一种解释型语言，
and it's meant to be sort of a laboratory or a playground for nerds like us to sort of go in and do matrix operations. So a lot of linear algebra, a lot of analysis of data, which is quite often stored in matrices. If you've ever used Excel, and Excel has a grid of cells, and a matrix also is a 2D grid of cells. So if you've ever used Excel, you've worked with something sort of analogous to a matrix, and it turns out that matrices are just very popular and almost ubiquitous in mathematics. And so this is sort of a place where you can go in and try different functions and do analysis at a high level. So MATLAB refers both to the language and to the
它旨在成为像我们这样的极客的实验室或游乐场，去进行矩阵运算。所以很多线性代数，很多数据分析，这些数据通常存储在矩阵中。如果你曾经使用过Excel，Excel有一个单元格网格，而矩阵也是一个2D单元格网格。所以如果你曾经使用过Excel，你已经使用过类似于矩阵的东西，事实证明矩阵在数学中非常流行，几乎无处不在。所以这有点像一个地方，你可以进去尝试不同的函数并在高层进行分析。所以MATLAB既指语言也指
product? That's right. So, you know, the scripting language that comes with MATLAB shares its name. And so often it can be a little bit confusing because you could say I'm talking about MATLAB, but you're talking about the code. Or you could say I'm talking about MATLAB the product. Oh, okay. So people use this? It's pretty popular? Yeah, so MATLAB is hugely popular, especially in the market of people who are sort of analyzing data. So linear control systems, guys who are doing servos, as Patrick was talking about earlier, and trying to create systems, robotics, tend to use a lot of MATLAB. People who are analyzing data, trying to generate statistics and regression and things like that, are definitely using MATLAB. Interesting. It's also really popular in school.
产品？没错。所以，你知道，MATLAB附带的脚本语言共享它的名字。所以通常这可能会有点令人困惑，因为你可以说我正在谈论MATLAB，但你谈论的是代码。或者你可以说我正在谈论MATLAB产品。哦，好的。所以人们使用这个？它很流行吗？是的，所以MATLAB非常流行，特别是在那些正在分析数据的人的市场中。所以线性控制系统，像Patrick早些时候谈到的做伺服电机的人，试图创建系统，机器人技术，倾向于使用大量的MATLAB。正在分析数据，试图生成统计数据和回归分析等的人，肯定在使用MATLAB。有趣。它在学校里也非常流行。
I remember in university that everybody seemed to be using it. All the professors at some point, just like all of a sudden, all the professors assumed you knew MATLAB. And I was like, no, wait, what? MATLAB? What's that? Yeah, I got burned by that, too. I went into image processing. It was a master's class. And yeah, he said that everyone will program their assignments in MATLAB. And I'd never seen MATLAB before. And, yeah, everyone has to kind of go through those moments. You know, in our case, it was MATLAB. Maybe some other people had the same situation with C.
我记得在大学里，每个人似乎都在使用它。所有的教授在某个时候，就像突然之间，所有的教授都假设你知道MATLAB。我当时想，不，等等，什么？MATLAB？那是什么？是的，我也被那个坑过。我参加了图像处理。那是一门硕士课程。是的，他说每个人都会用MATLAB编写他们的作业。我以前从未见过MATLAB。是的，每个人都必须经历那些时刻。你知道，在我们的例子中，它是MATLAB。也许其他人对C也有同样的情况。
But everyone goes to that moment where it's like, you know, you walk into either a job or a classroom, and someone says, everyone's doing everything in blah, MATLAB, Erlang, whatever. Oh, I would love it if I walked in and somebody said, we're going to do everything in Erlang. That would be pretty intense. Yeah, it would be a challenge. But one of the cool things about, you know, programming throwdown is that, you know, we're going to keep throwing down these languages. And at the end, we can get to the point where if you walk into a job interview and they say, here, we only use Haskell, you can step up to the plate and swing a home run by saying, oh, yeah, no problem. That would be pretty cool.
但每个人都会经历那个时刻，就像，你知道，你走进一份工作或教室，有人说，每个人都在用什么什么，MATLAB，Erlang，等等。哦，如果我走进去，有人说，我们要用Erlang做所有事情，我会很高兴的。那会很激烈。是的，那将是一个挑战。但Programming Throwdown很酷的一点是，你知道，我们将继续抛出这些语言。最后，我们可以达到这样一个地步，如果你走进一个工作面试，他们说，这里，我们只使用Haskell，你可以站出来，通过说“哦，是的，没问题”来打出一个全垒打。那会很酷。
So, yeah, so I remember when the first time my professor said, we got to use MATLAB. And I went online and like, all right, well, let me download MATLAB. And then I was like, oh, wait, hang on. Where's the download link and i went to the math works the company that makes matlab their website and like where do i get this and then i finally found a link and it said oh student version i'm like oh yeah let me get that one and it said a hundred dollars and i went what a hundred dollars for what what is this for my class oh Oh man. And then I quickly scrambled
所以，是的，所以我记得当我的教授第一次说，我们必须使用MATLAB。我上网，就像，好吧，好吧，让我下载MATLAB。然后我当时想，哦，等等，等等。下载链接在哪里？我去了MathWorks，制造MATLAB的公司，他们的网站，就像我在哪里得到这个？然后我终于找到了一个链接，它说哦，学生版。我当时想，哦，是的，让我得到那个。它说100美元，我当时想，什么？100美元为了什么？这是为了我的课吗？哦，天哪。然后我迅速挣扎
to find out that, you know, oh yeah, some, the university has an agreement to have it on their computers. And so I could go to the lab and use it there and avoid having to pay the a hundred dollars. But I know a lot of people who had to buy to have it on their computer. Yeah, definitely. So this is, this is Not so much in programming languages, thankfully, but it's common in the workplace and academia where you'll end up with vendor lock-in. Vendor lock-in. Yeah, vendor lock-in is the idea where... That sounds like a German word, vendor lock-in. It's happiness at the discomfort of others. Oh no, that's Scheidenfreude. But vendor lock-in is where, you know, you've started to use a product, say MATLAB.
去发现，你知道，哦，是的，一些，大学有一个协议在他们的电脑上有它。所以我可以去实验室使用它，避免不得不支付那100美元。但我知道很多人不得不买它才能在他们的电脑上使用。是的，绝对。所以这是，这是，谢天谢地，在编程语言中不是那么多，但在工作场所和学术界很常见，你会最终陷入供应商锁定。供应商锁定。是的，供应商锁定是这个想法，其中……听起来像一个德语单词，供应商锁定。这是对他人的不适感到快乐。哦，不，那是幸灾乐祸。但供应商锁定是，你知道，你已经开始使用一个产品，比如MATLAB。
Let's say you've used a free version of MATLAB at your university. All right. And so you become very acquainted with MATLAB. And I write awesome programs. That's right. You write a ton of MATLAB, and then you and some guys get together and say, you know what, we're awesome at MATLAB. We're going going to start a company and we're going to do linear systems consultation boring yeah worst company ever so so uh just kidding if that's your company we love you okay
假设你在大学里使用过免费版本的MATLAB。好的。所以你变得非常熟悉MATLAB。我编写很棒的程序。没错。你编写了大量的MATLAB，然后你和一些人聚在一起说，你知道吗，我们非常擅长MATLAB。我们要开始一家公司，我们要进行线性系统咨询。无聊，是的，有史以来最糟糕的公司。所以，所以，嗯，只是开个玩笑，如果那是你的公司，我们爱你。好的，
programming throwdown at five stars so um so so your company now is has had in its history an ingrenation of MATLAB. And so you're sort of, you know, for you to switch to another tool set, let's say you want to switch to Java or something, you'd have to rewrite everything. All of this code that's been built up over the years. I think I had that job when I was an intern. Converting MATLAB to C or Java? No, converting one language to another
Programming Throwdown五星好评。所以，嗯，所以你的公司现在在历史上已经有了MATLAB的印记。所以你有点，你知道，为了让你切换到另一个工具集，假设你想切换到Java或其他什么，你必须重写一切。所有这些多年来积累的代码。我想我在实习时有那份工作。将MATLAB转换为C或Java？不，将一种语言转换为另一种
that was really old something new oh rough uh yeah so this is vendor lock-in in other words matlab sort of has you in a position where you have to keep continuing to use matlab and to pay mathworks um to you know to stay successful as a business the cost of changing is worse than the cost of continuing to pay math works yeah exactly so so matlab is really powerful i mean where where i work that they use it all the time you know just tons of people use matlab it's really powerful they really love it they use it for doing prototyping stuff yeah um we'll get to some of the slowness problems later and why that people like you and I continue to be employed if everybody else could just use MATLAB. But so what is a person to do if they don't have a lot of money, if they don't want to be locked in? I mean, are there alternatives?
那真的很旧，某种新的。哦，粗糙。嗯，是的，所以这是供应商锁定。换句话说，MATLAB有点让你处于一个必须继续使用MATLAB并支付MathWorks的境地，嗯，为了，你知道，保持作为企业的成功。改变的成本比继续支付MathWorks的成本更糟糕。是的，完全正确。所以MATLAB真的很强大，我的意思是，我工作的地方，他们一直都在使用它，你知道，成吨的人使用MATLAB，它真的很强大，他们真的很喜欢它，他们用它来做原型设计。是的，嗯，我们稍后会谈到一些缓慢的问题，以及为什么像你我这样的人继续被雇佣，如果其他人都能使用MATLAB。但是，如果一个人没有很多钱，如果他们不想被锁定，该怎么办？我的意思是，有替代方案吗？
Yeah. So MATLAB, the language, has actually been re-implemented by another group, and it goes under the term Octave, or specifically GNU Octave. And so Octave is an open source, completely free and open source, implementation of the MATLAB language. And they advertise that any MATLAB program, any.m file, you should be able to run in Octave. Interesting. Yeah, so the one thing that Octave, they're starting to come up to speed on
是的。所以MATLAB，这种语言，实际上已经被另一个小组重新实现了，它被称为Octave，或者具体来说是GNU Octave。所以Octave是一个开源的，完全免费和开源的，MATLAB语言的实现。他们宣传说任何MATLAB程序，任何.m文件，你都应该能够在Octave中运行。有趣。是的，所以Octave的一件事，他们开始赶上速度了
but haven't quite fully flushed out yet is all of these toolkits that MATLAB has. I get one of those in my garage. Yeah, so this is sort of the bread and butter of MathWorks. They actually generate most of their business from selling these custom toolkits. And if you remember when we talked about Python and Erlang, we talked about their standard libraries. Batteries included, I remember. That's right.
但还没有完全充实的是MATLAB拥有的所有这些工具包。我在我的车库里有一个。是的，所以这是MathWorks的面包和黄油。他们实际上通过销售这些自定义工具包产生了他们大部分的业务。如果你还记得我们谈论Python和Erlang时，我们谈到了它们的标准库。电池包含在内，我记得。没错。
So what did Erlang do? It was OTP, right? Yep. Yeah, and then Python has... Open Telecom Platform. Yeah, and Python has a standard template or the standard Python library. But, you know, in the case of MATLAB, MATLAB relies on toolkits and they actually sell each toolkit or the majority of them. They sell, you know, one toolkit. So what is something that would be a toolkit? Yeah. So image processing, for example, might be a toolkit.
所以Erlang做了什么？它是OTP，对吧？没错。是的，然后Python有……开放电信平台。是的，Python有一个标准模板或标准Python库。但是，你知道，在MATLAB的情况下，MATLAB依赖于工具包，他们实际上销售每个工具包或其中的大部分。他们销售，你知道，一个工具包。所以什么是工具包？是的。所以图像处理，例如，可能是一个工具包。
Oh, yeah. Sometimes people do like to use images, use matrix to represent them. That's right, yeah. Yeah, so if you think an image is a 2D grid of pixels of different colors, and a matrix, as we mentioned, is similar to Excel. It's a grid of values. So they both can kind of, so a matrix can easily represent an image. And Matrix MATLAB's image processing toolkit comes with a bunch of functions that let you do different things like histogramming and blurring of images, doing convolutions.
哦，是的。有时人们确实喜欢使用图像，使用矩阵来表示它们。没错，是的。是的，所以如果你认为图像是不同颜色的像素的2D网格，而矩阵，正如我们提到的，类似于Excel。它是一个值的网格。所以它们都可以，所以矩阵可以很容易地表示图像。而MATLAB的图像处理工具包附带了一堆函数，让你做不同的事情，比如直方图和图像模糊，做卷积。
So these are all things that you could write yourself though right right so just like the standard library in python and erlang all of these like these toolkits are implemented in matlab now i'm talking about the programming language so you could easily write these toolkits yourself but this just saves you the hassle of having to write this and then ensuring that the code is sound and things like that interesting but so So the difference, though, is to reiterate, I guess, what you're saying is Python is free and the library is free. Right. Erlang can be had free and OTP is free. MATLAB is not free and does not include the toolkits,
所以这些都是你可以自己编写的东西，对吧？对，所以就像Python和Erlang中的标准库一样，所有这些，这些工具包都是用MATLAB实现的。现在我谈论的是编程语言，所以你可以很容易地自己编写这些工具包，但这只是省去了你必须编写这个，然后确保代码是健全的等等的麻烦。有趣。但是，所以区别，虽然，是重申，我想，你所说的是Python是免费的，库也是免费的。没错。Erlang可以免费获得，OTP也是免费的。MATLAB不是免费的，也不包括工具包，
which extend the functionality because you have to pay for those separately as well. Right. Now, Octave is working on, I think it's called OctaveForge, which is a repository of open source toolkits. And they've tried to mirror as best as possible a lot of the MATLAB toolkits. So there is an image processing toolkit for Octave. And actually, when I did the image processing class, I used Octave and the image processing toolkit for Octave. And my professor didn't even know that I was using Octave because he was still getting the.m files as my homework assignments and running them in MATLAB. You're a brave soul, sir. I know. I always
它们扩展了功能，因为你必须单独支付这些费用。没错。现在，Octave正在努力，我想它叫OctaveForge，这是一个开源工具包的存储库。他们试图尽可能好地镜像许多MATLAB工具包。所以有一个用于Octave的图像处理工具包。事实上，当我做图像处理课时，我使用了Octave和用于Octave的图像处理工具包。我的教授甚至不知道我在使用Octave，因为他仍然在接收.m文件作为我的家庭作业，并在MATLAB中运行它们。你是一个勇敢的灵魂，先生。我知道。我总是
wondered. It was sort of a risk I took, you know, when I submitted the homework, if there was a compatibility issue and I'd get a zero but uh but i can say a sample size of one but uh you know i did use octave and uh trusted it and it worked so good awesome awesome so these toolboxes you said are written in matlab files are they all written in matlab do they are all these dot m files are there other things that aren't written in matlab is matlab bootstrapped? Can you write a MATLAB interpreter in MATLAB? Is that how it's done?
想知道。当我提交作业时，这是一个我承担的风险，如果有一个兼容性问题，我会得到零分，但，嗯，但我可以说一个样本量为一，但，嗯，你知道，我确实使用了Octave，并且，信任它，它工作得很好。太棒了，太棒了。所以这些工具箱，你说的是用MATLAB文件编写的，它们都是用MATLAB编写的吗？它们都是这些.m文件吗？还有其他不是用MATLAB编写的东西吗？MATLAB是自举的吗？你可以在MATLAB中编写MATLAB解释器吗？这就是它的做法吗？
That's interesting. I think you could do that, right? But most of these MATLAB toolkits are written in C or C++, and there's something called a MEX file. And this is actually something that we didn't talk about too much in the past, but it merits some discussion which is the idea of extending the language or binding um um you know c and c plus plus code to the language is that like handcuffs yeah it's kind of it's a lot like going to prison sometimes it can feel like feel like you're in prison when you're writing extensions. Oh, okay, okay, all right. But no, for example, let's say you use the Zlib compression library
这很有趣。我想你可以那样做，对吧？但大多数这些MATLAB工具包是用C或C++编写的，有一个叫做MEX文件的东西。这实际上是我们过去没有谈论太多的东西，但它值得一些讨论，即扩展语言或绑定，嗯，嗯，你知道，C和C++代码到语言的想法。那就像手铐吗？是的，它很像去监狱，有时当你编写扩展时，它会感觉像在监狱里。哦，好的，好的，好吧。但不是，例如，假设你使用Zlib压缩库
and you want to do Zlib compression inside of MATLAB. So what you want to do is get at the Zlib C code from inside MATLAB. And that involves writing what's called a MEX file, which sort of lets you call C functions using the MATLAB virtual machine and so Python has the Python C API that lets you create PYD files which do the same thing so you can write C code and as long as you follow the Python API you can get to those C
并且你想在MATLAB中进行Zlib压缩。所以你想做的是从MATLAB内部获取Zlib C代码。这涉及到编写所谓的MEX文件，它有点让你使用MATLAB虚拟机调用C函数。所以Python有Python C API，让你创建做同样事情的PYD文件，所以你可以编写C代码，只要你遵循Python API，你就可以获取那些C
functions and variables from the Python API, you can get to those C functions and variables from the Python interpreter. Interesting. And the same way with Erlang. I don't know the specifics on that, but you can do the same thing there, and in MATLAB you can do the same thing with MEX files. So the majority of these toolkits are written in C or C++ with just the MEX wrapper around them.
函数和变量从Python API，你可以从Python解释器获取那些C函数和变量。有趣。Erlang也是一样。我不知道那方面的具体细节，但你可以在那里做同样的事情，在MATLAB中你可以用MEX文件做同样的事情。所以大多数这些工具包是用C或C++编写的，只是周围有MEX包装器。
That's pretty cool. Pretty cool. So MATLAB is an instance where they do write it in something else instead of writing it in itself. Right. So, you know, MATLAB... And it says here that GNU Octave is written in C and C++ for sure. Right. Yeah, so most of MATLAB is written in other languages, in lower-level languages.
那很酷。很酷。所以MATLAB是一个实例，他们确实用其他东西编写它，而不是用它自己编写。没错。所以，你知道，MATLAB……这里说GNU Octave肯定是C和C++编写的。没错。是的，所以大多数MATLAB是用其他语言，低级语言编写的。
But there are parts which are written in just MATLAB. Yeah, so is MATLAB, here's a question, I'm going to put you on the hot seat. Oh, here we go. So is MATLAB a compiled or an interpreted or a semi-compiled language? Well, okay, so let's use what we've learned on the podcast so far so sounded like i heard that it it did some sort of pre-looking at it almost like the python files so it doesn't completely just interpreted so i'm and i'm pretty sure it's not completely compiled so i'm gonna go with the hybrid between the two yeah definitely, definitely. You got it.
但有些部分是用MATLAB编写的。是的，所以MATLAB，这是一个问题，我要把你放在热座上。哦，开始了。所以MATLAB是编译型、解释型还是半编译型语言？好吧，好吧，让我们使用我们在播客中学到的东西，所以听起来我听说它确实做了一些预先查看，几乎像Python文件，所以它不完全只是解释型的，所以我很确定它不完全是编译型的，所以我选择两者之间的混合体。是的，绝对，绝对。你答对了。
Oh, I need a buzzer sound on my ringer. Bing! Yay! What do I win? You win another question. Is MATLAB statically or dynamically typed? Ooh, good question. Yeah. Have we even talked about this? I don't think we have talked about this.
哦，我需要在我的铃声上加一个蜂鸣声。叮！耶！我赢了什么？你赢了另一个问题。MATLAB是静态类型还是动态类型？噢，好问题。是的。我们甚至谈过这个吗？我不认为我们谈过这个。
This is a first. Maybe you should introduce typing. Okay, so oh, I don't know. Here we go. We'll try. So, static versus dynamic typing. Well, let's try to give it short and sweet. Okay. Because we could go on a long time about this. And there's all sorts of variations in between and all sorts of which one's better than the other. And as I think our stand is on this podcast, we're all about right tool for the right problem, you know, expanding your toolbox so you'll be able to solve the problem with the best tool possible. And I think dynamic and static typing fall into that, something that is appropriate for different situations.
这是第一次。也许你应该介绍一下类型。好的，所以哦，我不知道。开始了。我们会尝试。所以，静态类型与动态类型。好吧，让我们试着简短而甜蜜。好的。因为我们可以谈论很长时间。中间有各种各样的变化，也有各种各样哪一个比另一个更好。正如我认为我们在播客上的立场，我们都是关于解决问题的正确工具，你知道，扩展你的工具箱，这样你就能用最好的工具解决问题。我认为动态和静态类型属于这一点，适合不同情况的东西。
So dynamic typing, and you correct me if I'm wrong, basically means the first time that you have a variable. So I have the variable letter X and I say X equals 3 the compiler at it or the thing that has to run the program if I don't tell it what X is has to look and say oh you're sticking the number 3 and X that must be and then at runtime dynamically has to decide oh that must be an integer or if I said 3.1 it has to say that's a float or a double. And then later, being dynamic makes the thing that's running at the interpreter have to work a little harder.
所以动态类型，如果你纠正我，如果我错了，基本上意味着你第一次拥有一个变量。所以我有一个变量字母X，我说X等于3，编译器，或者必须运行程序的那个东西，如果我不告诉它X是什么，它必须看并说，哦，你把数字3放在X里，那必须是，然后在运行时动态地必须决定，哦，那必须是一个整数，或者如果我说3.1，它必须说那是一个浮点数或双精度数。然后后来，动态使得运行解释器的那个东西必须工作得更努力一点。
But then later, it allows me to do things like then I could set x equal to the string hello world. And it can change it for me and say, oh, look, now x is a string. And x doesn't even have to really be a string as long as it knows what's stored there and what currently is there. Versus static means, and this is something that's common to like C and Java and C++, means you have to actually say what type of variable is when you declare it the first time you kind of use it. And so instead of just saying X equals three, I need to say
但后来，它允许我做一些事情，比如我可以把 x 设为字符串“hello world”。它能为我改变它，并说：“哦，看，现在 x 是一个字符串了。”而且 x 甚至不需要真的是一个字符串，只要它知道那里存储了什么以及当前是什么就行。相比之下，静态类型意味着——这在 C、Java 和 C++ 中很常见——你必须在第一次使用变量时实际声明它的类型。所以，与其只说 X 等于 3，我需要说
int x equals 3. And telling the compiler, the interpreter, this variable is, shall be, and shall remain an integer. And that gives it some opportunity to do enhancements, but means that later on I can't decide, oh, I want to reuse x
int x 等于 3。告诉编译器或解释器，这个变量是、应当是，并且将保持为一个整数。这给了它一些进行优化的机会，但也意味着以后我不能决定“哦，我想重用 x”
in the same scope and make it a string now. Because I go, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. You told me that was an int. Can't make it a string now, buddy. That's right. Yeah, so one of the things about dynamic typing is that it can create a lot of runtime errors because you can do things that you didn't expect, things that would be caught at compile time.
在同一个作用域内把它变成一个字符串。因为它会说：“哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。你告诉过我那是个整数。伙计，现在不能把它变成字符串。”没错。是的，动态类型的一个特点是它可能会产生很多运行时错误，因为你可以做一些你没预料到的事情，而这些事情本可以在编译时被捕获。
So, for example, going on to what Patrick was saying, if you say, let's say later on in your code, you have, you know, z equals x plus y. If x is three and y is four, then, you know, that's fine. It can do that addition. But if in between there, you say x equals hello world, and then you try and add hello world and four, that's going to cause a runtime error. Now, you know, in a language with static typing, it knows before it even runs the code that x is a string or an integer. And so it knows that when you've done x plus y, that combination is not valid. You can't add hello world and for. It doesn't make sense. So a dynamically typed language gives you more freedom, but at the same time allows you to make a mistake at runtime,
所以，举个例子，接着帕特里克刚才说的，如果你在代码后面写了 z 等于 x 加 y。如果 x 是 3，y 是 4，那么这没问题，它可以进行加法运算。但如果在这中间，你说 x 等于“hello world”，然后你尝试把“hello world”和 4 相加，那就会导致运行时错误。现在，你知道，在静态类型语言中，它在运行代码之前就知道 x 是字符串还是整数。所以它知道当你执行 x 加 y 时，这种组合是无效的。你不能把“hello world”和 4 相加，这说不通。所以动态类型语言给了你更多的自由，但同时也让你更容易在运行时犯错，
which can crash your program. Oh, okay, interesting. So back to the original question, MATLAB, having done a little bit of it, I think it's dynamic. That's right. Yeah, MATLAB's definitely dynamically typed. Because I've definitely said, you know, A equals X transpose and not had to tell it what it was. In fact, I don't even know what it was.
这可能会导致你的程序崩溃。哦，好的，有意思。回到最初的问题，MATLAB，我用过一点，我觉得它是动态类型的。没错。是的，MATLAB 绝对是动态类型的。因为我肯定写过 A 等于 X 的转置，而不需要告诉它那是什么。事实上，我甚至不知道那是什么。
Some matrix. I don't even know what the type was. So it must be dynamic. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. MATLAB's dynamically typed. And that gets to a topic that's a little interesting on virtual machine latency. That sounds bad.
某个矩阵。我甚至不知道它的类型是什么。所以它一定是动态的。是的。是的，绝对是。MATLAB 是动态类型的。这引出了一个关于虚拟机延迟的有趣话题。听起来很糟糕。
Yeah, this is sort of the Achilles heel of MATLAB. As Patrick was alluding to, this is how we see in C++ and Java guys have jobs still. And, you know, let's look at dynamic typing, for example. MATLAB does x plus y. So let's just look at that function. It has to know what x and y are. And then based on that, it has to call a different addition. So if x is an integer, if x is a matrix of integers and y is a matrix of integers,
是的，这算是 MATLAB 的阿喀琉斯之踵。正如帕特里克所暗示的，这就是为什么我们看到 C++ 和 Java 的程序员依然有工作的原因。而且，你看，以动态类型为例。MATLAB 执行 x 加 y。我们来看看那个函数。它必须知道 x 和 y 是什么。然后基于此，它必须调用不同的加法函数。所以如果 x 是整数，如果 x 是整数矩阵，y 也是整数矩阵，
it has a certain function that adds those two. If x is a matrix of floating point, x and y are floating point matrices, it has a different function that operates on floating point. And so for every instruction that you execute in MATLAB, it has to do a lot of thinking, as opposed to C, where every instruction corresponds to one or at most a handful of machine code, of assembly code instructions. And the compiler only has to do a lot of thinking still, but it knows a lot and it only has to do it once. And then it generates an executable which can run many, many times. Right, exactly. So, you know, in the case of C, for example, or let's look at C++.
它有一个特定的函数来相加。如果 x 是浮点矩阵，x 和 y 都是浮点矩阵，它就有另一个处理浮点数的函数。所以对于你在 MATLAB 中执行的每一条指令，它都必须进行大量的思考，这与 C 语言不同，在 C 语言中，每一条指令对应一条或最多几条机器码（汇编指令）。编译器仍然需要进行大量的思考，但它知道得很多，而且只需要思考一次。然后它生成一个可以运行很多次的可执行文件。对，没错。所以，你知道，以 C 语言为例，或者我们看看 C++。
C++ has a function called find where you can give it the beginning and the end of an array and a value to look for. And it'll return if it found that value or not. That calling the find function is about the same, will take about the same time as looping through the array yourself and looking for the value. Okay. But in MATLAB, calling the find function is much, much faster than looping through the array and looking for the value. So if you're looking for five and you just call find my matrix comma five, that will return instantly.
C++ 有一个名为 find 的函数，你可以给它数组的开头和结尾以及要查找的值。它会返回是否找到了该值。调用 find 函数所花费的时间，大约和你自己遍历数组查找该值的时间差不多。好的。但在 MATLAB 中，调用 find 函数比遍历数组查找该值要快得多。所以如果你在找 5，你只需要调用 find(my_matrix, 5)，它会立即返回。
But if you loop through your matrix... Literally instantly? It'll return in nanoseconds. Or let's say... A short amount of time. A handful of microseconds. But if you do, you know, if you have a gigantic array
但如果你遍历你的矩阵……真的立即返回吗？它会在纳秒内返回。或者说……很短的时间。几微秒。但如果你，你知道，如果你有一个巨大的数组
and you write a for loop in MATLAB that just loops through the array and checks for five, that will take on the order of seconds. So it will take, you know, a million times longer for you to loop through. And that's because you're executing a million times as many instructions. And each instruction has this VM, virtual machine latency, has this overhead associated with it. So that's because each time when you do the find, you just have to look up the applicable function to call once.
并且你在 MATLAB 中写了一个 for 循环来遍历数组并检查 5，那将需要几秒钟的时间。所以你遍历的时间会比它长一百万倍。这是因为你执行的指令多了一百万倍。而且每条指令都有这种虚拟机延迟，有与之相关的开销。所以这是因为每次你执行 find 时，你只需要查找一次适用的函数来调用。
But when you're looping it over, every time it gets there, it has to try and figure out what it's doing because because it's dynamic, it could have changed. That's right. So that, you know, if you're doing it yourself, you loop through the array and you say, you know, does the matrix at this index equal five? And the matrix might have changed, like the variable might not be a matrix anymore. The matrix index might have changed. Maybe that's not an int or maybe something weird has happened to that.
但当你循环遍历时，每次到达那里，它都必须尝试弄清楚它在做什么，因为它是动态的，它可能已经改变了。没错。所以，你知道，如果你自己做这件事，你遍历数组并说：“这个索引处的矩阵等于 5 吗？”矩阵可能已经改变了，比如变量可能不再是矩阵了。矩阵索引可能已经改变了。也许那不是整数，或者发生了什么奇怪的事情。
What it means to index a matrix, it has to, you know, look that up. Versus in C, the compiler has done all that. And it's just coming down to is this address equal to five and that's a single instruction on the CPU. The value stored at this address equal to five. Right that's right so yeah so you know the VM the virtual machine overhead in MATLAB is extremely extremely high and that's why a lot of things that are prototyped in MATLAB, but are meant for like a production environment, are then recoded in C or C++ or Java or some other language that doesn't have this overhead. So from what you tell me, you know, I'd be kind of bummed about MATLAB.
索引矩阵意味着什么，它必须去查找。而在 C 语言中，编译器已经完成了所有这些工作。它只是归结为“这个地址的值等于 5 吗”，这在 CPU 上是一条单一指令。存储在这个地址的值等于 5。对，没错。所以，你知道，MATLAB 中的虚拟机开销非常非常高，这就是为什么许多在 MATLAB 中原型设计，但旨在用于生产环境的东西，随后会被用 C、C++、Java 或其他没有这种开销的语言重写。所以照你这么说，我会对 MATLAB 有点失望。
Sounds kind of like, why would I pay this Math math works company money to have it or go to the effort of using gnu octave instead of just using cr python but i've had a lot of people at work tell me how awesome matlab is and then they tell me that they are using like like you got to do a huge sparse matrix computation and i my eyes cringe thinking i'd have to go write code and see to be able to do that. Or they're doing some Fourier transform. And I don't even know. It's so complicated. I had to look at my textbook to figure out what it was. So why are these guys saying that MATLAB is really powerful and they're able to do those operations fast? Yeah. So MATLAB is extremely optimized. So the way this works is, let's say in MATLAB you want to add two matrices together. You don't have to use a for loop like you would in C and loop through all of these matrices and add all of the different values at each index together.
听起来像是，我为什么要花钱给 MathWorks 公司买它，或者费力去用 GNU Octave，而不是直接用 C 或 Python？但我工作中有很多人告诉我 MATLAB 有多棒，然后他们告诉我他们正在做类似巨大的稀疏矩阵计算，我想到必须去写 C 代码来实现这一点就感到头疼。或者他们正在做某种傅里叶变换。我甚至不知道。太复杂了。我得查教科书才能弄明白那是什么。那么为什么这些人说 MATLAB 非常强大，而且他们能够快速完成这些操作呢？是的。所以 MATLAB 是经过极度优化的。它的工作方式是，假设在 MATLAB 中你想把两个矩阵相加。你不需要像在 C 语言中那样使用 for 循环，遍历这些矩阵并在每个索引处把不同的值加在一起。
You can just say, you know, if you have matrices A and B, you could just say C equals A plus B. And what MATLAB does under the hood is it recognizes that they're matrices and it has a very optimized C version. So in other words, someone maybe that was their full-time job was just to write this function that adds, you know, and does arithmetic on matrices. So they might use SSE instructions. That's right. So it'll check and see what the capabilities of your computer are. If your computer supports SSE instructions, which stands for, what is it, SIMD extensions, standard SIMD extensions.
你只需要说，如果你有矩阵 A 和 B，你只需要说 C 等于 A 加 B。MATLAB 在底层所做的是它识别出它们是矩阵，并且它有一个非常优化的 C 语言版本。换句话说，可能有人全职工作就是为了编写这个函数，用来进行矩阵的算术运算。所以他们可能会使用 SSE 指令。没错。所以它会检查并查看你计算机的功能。如果你的计算机支持 SSE 指令，也就是所谓的 SIMD 扩展，标准 SIMD 扩展。
And maybe we'll talk about that when we talk about C++ or something. Yeah, that could be a whole topic in itself probably. Yeah, yeah, definitely. If your computer has any of these extensions, it'll try and use them. If your computer has a GPU, which is something maybe we'll talk about later, it can use the graphics processing unit to do some of these matrix operations. And so MATLAB will sort of query your hardware and say, you know, based on your configuration, I can add these two matrices even faster using X, Y, and Z. Versus, you know, if
也许我们在谈论 C++ 或其他什么的时候会谈到这个。是的，那本身可能就是一个完整的话题。是的，绝对是。如果你的计算机有任何这些扩展，它会尝试使用它们。如果你的计算机有 GPU，这也许我们以后会谈到，它可以使用图形处理器来执行其中一些矩阵运算。所以 MATLAB 会查询你的硬件并说：“根据你的配置，我可以使用 X、Y 和 Z 更快地将这两个矩阵相加。”相比之下，你知道，如果你
you're writing in C, you're probably just going to write the addition code in for loops and that it won't use any of these optimized hardware. I see, I see. So if you're using their functions and using them in a way, so Fourier transform, they've gone in and made that thing awesome. Right. If I go code one, mine will work and probably beat by far the one that you write yourself in MATLAB. But they've already taken time to go write one that's kick butt, and it'll sure kick the butt of my code. Right.
用 C 语言编写，你可能只是用 for 循环编写加法代码，它不会使用任何这些优化的硬件。我明白了，我明白了。所以如果你使用他们的函数，以某种方式使用它们，比如傅里叶变换，他们已经进去并把那个东西做得非常棒了。没错。如果我自己去写一个，我的代码能运行，而且可能远胜于你自己用 MATLAB 写的代码。但他们已经花时间去写了一个非常厉害的函数，它肯定会打败我的代码。没错。
I mean, those guys make a living just figuring out how to do matrix arithmetic and Fourier transform and cosine transform and things like that. There's people who that's their job. they're naturally, they're going to do it and test it and optimize it much better than someone whose job is to do image processing. And they're just having to do Fourier transform as a consequence of that. So they are, you know, the positives of it is they have the expertise of the low-level, you know, architects that design MATLAB. They have that going behind them, even though they don't necessarily know how that stuff works under the hood. So what about Octave? So MathWorks has a number of employees. I don't know how many.
我的意思是，那些人靠研究如何进行矩阵算术、傅里叶变换、余弦变换等工作为生。有专门的人做这份工作。他们自然会比那些工作是做图像处理，而只是顺便做傅里叶变换的人做得更好、测试得更充分、优化得更好。所以，你知道，它的积极方面是他们拥有设计 MATLAB 的底层架构师的专业知识。他们有这些作为后盾，尽管他们不一定知道这些东西在底层是如何工作的。那么 Octave 呢？MathWorks 有很多员工。我不知道有多少。
I'm sure a lot. And they sit here and do all this awesome stuff. And you said earlier something that I thought was interesting. Octave is a re-implementation of the MATLAB language or an implementation of it. It's not MathWorks one because they obviously can't use MathWorks code. That's protected. And they probably can't even look at it because then some of it might accidentally end up in there and they could get in all sorts of trouble.
我肯定很多。他们坐在那里做所有这些很棒的事情。你刚才说了一些我觉得很有趣的话。Octave 是 MATLAB 语言的重新实现或一种实现。它不是 MathWorks 的，因为他们显然不能使用 MathWorks 的代码。那是受保护的。而且他们可能甚至不能看它，因为那样的话，其中一些代码可能会意外地出现在里面，他们可能会惹上各种麻烦。
So they recreate all of that stuff. So how does Octave speed compare to MATLAB? So Octave, from my limited experience, Octave is a little slower than MATLAB. There was a time where I did take some of my code
所以他们重新创建了所有这些东西。那么 Octave 的速度与 MATLAB 相比如何？所以 Octave，根据我有限的经验，Octave 比 MATLAB 稍微慢一点。曾经有一段时间，我确实把我的一些代码
and run it on MATLAB, code that I developed in Octave. I noticed it was slightly faster. But a lot of the limitations that we've talked about, I mean, a lot of the, especially people who are novices like myself at MATLAB, the slowness or the speed will be a result of using too many lines of code and just hitting the virtual machine too often. So for example, you might want to do something that you think is very
在 MATLAB 上运行，那些代码是我在 Octave 中开发的。我注意到它稍微快一点。但我们谈到的很多限制，我的意思是，很多，特别是像我这样在 MATLAB 方面的新手，缓慢或速度将是使用太多行代码并过于频繁地触及虚拟机的结果。所以例如，你可能想做一些你认为非常
complex. Like, for example, if you want to loop through the matrix and if the value is greater than 0.5, you want to do something. So you might think, how am I going to do this without a for loop? Because there's logic here and I have different branches. And MATLAB will actually do those things. There's single commands that can sort of return all the locations that are greater than 0.5 or greater than some threshold. And if you're clever in MATLAB, you can reduce the number of instructions you're giving it and still do really complicated things. And if you're clever in MATLAB, you can reduce the number of instructions you're giving it and still do really complicated things. And if you're doing that, your code's going to be very fast, whether you're using Octave or MATLAB. But yeah, overall, MATLAB, because they've spent so much time optimizing for different computers,
复杂的事情。比如，如果你想遍历矩阵，如果值大于 0.5，你想做点什么。所以你可能会想，我怎么能在没有 for 循环的情况下做到这一点？因为这里有逻辑，我有不同的分支。而 MATLAB 实际上可以做到这些。有单一的命令可以返回所有大于 0.5 或大于某个阈值的位置。如果你在 MATLAB 中很聪明，你可以减少你给它的指令数量，仍然可以做非常复杂的事情。如果你在 MATLAB 中很聪明，你可以减少你给它的指令数量，仍然可以做非常复杂的事情。如果你这样做，你的代码会非常快，无论你使用的是 Octave 还是 MATLAB。但总的来说，MATLAB，因为他们花了很多时间为不同的计算机进行优化，
is going to be a little bit faster. Well, I think that's a pretty good overview of the two languages. Do you have any other comments? You know, we kind of talk about learning sometimes, but MATLAB, Octave, I mean, there's tons of stuff out there, lots of good stuff, a lot of books written, a lot of professors use this. There's a lot of tutorials on university websites. Yeah, that's a good point.
会稍微快一点。嗯，我认为这是对这两种语言的一个很好的概述。你还有其他评论吗？你知道，我们有时会谈论学习，但 MATLAB、Octave，我的意思是，外面有很多东西，很多好东西，写了很多书，很多教授使用这个。大学网站上有很多教程。是的，这是一个很好的观点。
If you're in university, chances are one of your you know electrical engineering computer engineering classes is going to have a you know intro on MATLAB often they won't teach it to you you'll have to you know they'll leave it up to you to read it but at least they'll have the material there and I know that at UCF and probably even at UF that stuff's public so you could even get on the the UCF website and read their tutorial on MATLAB without being a student. Awesome. Well, you want to close it out there? Yeah, unless you have anything to say about MATLAB. What about applications?
如果你在大学，很有可能你的电气工程或计算机工程课程中会有一个 MATLAB 入门。通常他们不会教你，他们会让你自己去读，但至少他们会有材料在那里。我知道在 UCF，可能甚至在 UF，这些东西是公开的，所以你甚至可以在 UCF 网站上阅读他们的 MATLAB 教程，而不需要成为一名学生。太棒了。好吧，你想在这里结束吗？是的，除非你对 MATLAB 有什么要说的。应用方面呢？
Like what kind of stuff? Did you use MATLAB on your Arduino? Probably not, right? No, no. Yeah, so, you know, we talked a little bit about projects using Erlang last week. That might be a good segment. But then for MATLAB, it's a little hard to use. People don't – there are some GUIs and stuff written.
比如什么样的东西？你在 Arduino 上用过 MATLAB 吗？可能没有，对吧？没有，没有。是的，所以，你知道，我们上周谈了一些使用 Erlang 的项目。那可能是一个很好的环节。但对于 MATLAB，它有点难用。人们不——虽然写了一些 GUI 之类的东西。
But because of the nature of most people using MATLAB from MathWorks that, you know, people don't want – they can't give you a program to run necessarily without you having to buy your own license. That's expensive propositions. There aren't a lot of applications written in it. But yeah, I mean, I've used it in school, especially in some at work for doing, like you said, a lot of image processing.
但由于大多数人使用 MathWorks 的 MATLAB 的性质，人们不想——他们不一定能给你一个程序运行，而不需要你自己购买许可证。那是昂贵的提议。用它编写的应用程序并不多。但是的，我的意思是，我在学校用过它，特别是在工作中做一些，就像你说的，大量的图像处理。
That was a use for it. Also doing some linear algebra type stuff like optimizations and stuff there and some controls stuff was was there as well so yeah i used it for a number of those kind of projects i never had to write anything that was a substantial line count or a big complicated project because it's just not really one time i tried to make a gui but it's just not i didn't find it well suited for that right yeah i've noticed the same thing that matlab doesn't really sort of play well with others
那是一个用途。还有做一些线性代数类型的东西，比如优化之类的，还有一些控制方面的东西也在那里，所以是的，我用它做了很多这类项目。我从来不需要写任何行数很多或大型复杂项目的东西，因为它真的不适合。有一次我尝试制作一个 GUI，但我发现它不太适合。对，是的，我也注意到了同样的事情，MATLAB 真的不太能与他人“友好相处”
in the sense that, you know, you can write, as we talked about, those MEX files, but the interface is very cumbersome. And MathWorks, you know, they're in the business of sort of writing extensions for MATLAB. And if they make it really easy for you to interface MATLAB with other aspects of your system, then they're sort of working against themselves there to some extent. But with that said,
从某种意义上说，你知道，你可以编写我们谈到的那些 MEX 文件，但接口非常繁琐。而且 MathWorks，你知道，他们从事的是为 MATLAB 编写扩展的业务。如果他们让你非常容易地将 MATLAB 与你系统的其他方面连接起来，那么他们在某种程度上是在与自己作对。但话虽如此，
MATLAB is a phenomenal tool for prototyping, for doing data analysis. One thing we didn't talk about, but MATLAB comes with a graphing tool built in. So you can actually go into MATLAB or Octave. You can download Octave right now, type in sine of x, and it'll actually display a graph of the sine wave on your computer. And so that is just all of this extra visualization tools that you don't get in many languages. It makes it great for doing a quick prototype before jumping into C or C++.
MATLAB 是一个用于原型设计、进行数据分析的非凡工具。我们没有谈到的一点是，MATLAB 自带了一个绘图工具。所以你实际上可以进入 MATLAB 或 Octave。你现在就可以下载 Octave，输入 sine(x)，它实际上会在你的电脑上显示正弦波的图形。所以这就是所有这些额外的可视化工具，你在许多语言中都得不到。这使得它非常适合在跳入 C 或 C++ 之前进行快速原型设计。
Yeah, definitely. Yeah. All right. Well, if you haven't checked out our blog at programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com, make sure to check that out. Also, if you haven't left a review for us or given us a star rating, please go ahead and do that. If you us make sure to tell us if you hate us well you can tell us that too rate us five stars because we're so hate inducing so yeah go ahead and leave your and those of you who have
是的，绝对是。是的。好吧，如果你还没有查看我们的博客 programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com，一定要去看看。另外，如果你还没有给我们留下评论或给予星级评分，请继续这样做。如果你——一定要告诉我们你是否讨厌我们，好吧，你也可以告诉我们，给我们五星好评，因为我们太招人恨了，所以是的，继续留下你的，那些已经
thank you a bunch it's really encouraging helps us keep our spirits up and wanting to keep doing this and hopefully we'll continue to hear back from some of you about what you like or what you don't like what you'd like to see in the future what you'd prefer for us to stop doing, how much you love Jason or how much you love me. Either one will work.
非常感谢你们，这真的很令人鼓舞，帮助我们保持精神振奋，并希望继续这样做。希望我们能继续收到你们的反馈，关于你们喜欢什么或不喜欢什么，你们希望在未来看到什么，你们希望我们停止做什么，你们有多爱杰森或者你们有多爱我。两者都行。
And, yeah, check it out. Yeah, if you don't give us any love on iTunes, we might have to start Lacrimology, which is a religion that this is off Wikipedia here, a religion that supposedly embraces pain, and it's released through crying as a means to move to a higher state of being. This is... Okay, with that, I think we're
而且，是的，去看看吧。是的，如果你不在 iTunes 上给我们一点爱，我们可能不得不开始“悲伤学”（Lacrimology），这是维基百科上的一个宗教，一个据说拥抱痛苦的宗教，通过哭泣来释放，作为进入更高存在状态的一种手段。这是……好吧，有了这个，我想我们
going to be done. Until next time! Alright, have a good one, guys. Keep on programming. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要结束了。下次见！好的，祝你们过得愉快，伙计们。继续编程。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下发布，你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品以进行重混、改编，但你必须注明帕特里克和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。